bonjour à tous monsieur le ministre
bonjour l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à soutenir les femmes qui
souffrent
d'endométriose et pour ouvrir ce débat
la parole est au rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour 10
minutes Monsieur Emmanuel Tachet de la
Pagerie
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
selon Simone de beauauvoir la femme
n'est victime d'aucune mystérieuse
fatalité il ne faut pas conclure que ces
s la condamnent à vivre éternellement à
genoux il est donc des sujets à propos
desquels la représentation nationale
doit et et peut faire
preuve en direction de l'intérêt général
prendre ses responsabilités en faisant
abstraction de combinaisons politique
pour répondre à des défis imminents et
cruciaux indéiablement la proposition de
loi que je porte devant vous aujourd'hui
en étint membre assidu de la délégation
aux droits des femmes rapporteur de la
proposition de loi visant à la création
d'une aide universelle d'urgence pour
les victimes de violence conjugale voté
en janvier dernier à l'unanimité dans
cet hémicycle et au Sénat je vous
propose aujourd'hui d'avancer
concrètement en créant notamment une
infection de longue durée exonérante
spécifique aux femmes atteintes
d'endométriose c'est là à faire le choix
d'un progrès social évident et d'un
engagement collectif concernant nos
concitoyennes c'est aussi dans la
logique de la lettre au fr de Marine Le
Pen du 7 mars 2022 que s'inscrit notre
démarche et notre volonté selon la
définition posée par l'incerme
l'endométriose est une maladie
gynécologique fréquente qui concerne une
femme sur 10 elle est liée à la présence
de tissu semblable à la muqueuse utérine
en dehors de l'utérus différents organes
peuvent être touchés la maladie
peut-être asymptomatique mais dans
certains cas elle provoque des douleurs
fortes notamment au moment des règles et
ou une infertilité les chercheurs
tentent de mieux connaître les
mécanismes de cette maladie et ses liens
avec l'in fertilité dans un couple
chacun sait que l'endométriose
correspond à la difficulté voire
l'impossibilité de concevoir un enfant
cette maladie est la première cause
d'infertilité en France impactant entre
20 et 68 % des femmes l'endométriose
c'est encore la douleur pendant les
rapports sexuels l'irritabilité la
dépression voire les pensées suicidaires
à cet égard et dans le prolongement du
rapport d'information d'allégation au
droits des femmes de l'Assemblée
nationale du 11 juillet 2023 j'alerte
sur l'enjeu de santé mentale des femmes
que peut soulever aussi l'endométriose
vous l'aurez compris ce propos liminaire
invite l'ensemble des bans à prendre de
la hauteur et à agir concrètement
certaines interventions en commission
travers travestisser pardon l'ambition
de la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et niaer la
réalité subie par plus d'un million de
femmes dans notre pays chers collègues
lorsqu'il s'agit de la santé des femmes
les controverses les atermoimements et
les attaques politiciennes ne sont pas
digne et non pas lieu d'être je le dis
car j'ai lu et entendu des propos qui
sur le fond et la forme ne nomme
personne je vous rappelle qu'aucun
prétexte ne peut excuser l'inaction dans
les fait et tel que rédigé l'article 1
vise à créer une affection de longue
durée exonérante spécifique aux femmes
atteintes d'endométriose afin de prendre
précisément en compte les spécificités
de cette maladie et de faire face à des
dispositifs de prise en charge
institutionnelle trop restrictif à
savoir l'AL 30 et 31 par la création
d'une al exonérante spécifique cet
article répond à la diversité des
situations vécues et subies par les
femmes atteintes d'endométriose alors
que la proposition de résolution adoptée
à l'unanimité le 13 janvier 2022 n'a
jamais été appliquée par le gouvernement
alors que la stratégie nationale de
lutte contre contre l'endométriose mise
en œuvre à 85 % d'après le ministère de
la Santé ne répond pas dans les délais
raisonnables à la hauteur de l'enjeu le
législateur doit agir le cadre actuel
permettant à des femmes atteintes
d'endométrios d'être reconnu en ald31 a
montré son insuffisance la
reconnaissance en al31 demeure aussi
exceptionnelle qu'aléatoire en 2022 seul
13472 femmes atteintes d'endométriose
étaient reconnues en al 31 soit 0,6 %
des femmes atteintes d'endométriose la
ld31 est également source d'inégalité
territoriale d'après laacnam en 2022 le
taux d'acceptation des demandes en al 31
s'estélevé à 31,86 % en Bretagne contre
79,40 % pour le territoire géographique
de l'exrégion midi pyrénée pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons la création
d'une al spécifique concernant les
femmes atteintes d'endométriose est
cruciale concrètement si vous adoptez
cette proposition de loi les frais de
santé liés à l'endométriose seront pris
en charge à 100 % dans la limite du
plafond de remboursement de l'Assurance
Maladie cette exonération du ticket
modérateur concernerait les
consultations examin et soins
médicaments ainsi que l'hospitalisation
les frais de santé en rapport avec
l'endométriose n'auraient pas à être
avancé toutes les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose bénéficieront du tiers
payant serait aussi assuré
la prise en charge des frais de
transport en lien avec l'endométriose il
n'y aurait plus de délai de carence en
cas d'arrêt de travail successif d'après
la circulaire du 26 mai 2015 le premier
arrêt de travail lié à une ALD ne peut
donner lieu à une indemnisation qu'à
comptter du 4e jour d'arrêt de travail
en revanche en cas d'arrêt de travail
successif lié à une même al le délai de
carence ne s'applique qu'une seule fois
au cours du même d'une même période de 3
ans à cet effet l'absence de délai de
carence en cas d'arrêt de travail
successif centrale pour toutes les
femmes atteintes d'endométriose
d'ailleurs laacnam compte en moyenne 33
jours d'arrêt de travail par an pour les
femmes concerné et reconnu en al 31
l'intérêt de ce texte est précisément
d'inscrire dans la loi l'endométriose et
inserit d'en joindre le gouvernement à
agir concrètement pour 1,5 à 2,5
millions de femmes dans notre pays en
cas d'adoption de l'article 1 de cette
proposition de loi le gouvernement sera
tenu de prendre un décret reconnaissant
l'endométriose comme affection de longue
durée exonérante spécifique conformément
à l'article L
174 du code de la sécurité sociale dent
modifié par l'article 1 de la
proposition de loi l'article 2 quant à
lui vise à permettre aux femmes
diagnostiquer qu' le souhaite d'être
reconnu en qualité de travailleur
handicapés ainsi cet article donne la
possibilité d'aménager les horaires de
travail et le poste de travail par la
mise par la mise en place quand cela est
possible du du télétravail il s'agit
d'un vecteur d'égalité et de
visibilisation des femmes dans le monde
professionnel quant au diagnostic de
l'endométriose précisément selon le
rapport d'information relatif à la santé
des femmes au travail de la délégation
au droits des femmes du Sénat du 27 juin
2023 nous pourrions nous inspirer du
test salivaire de diagnosticque de
l'endométriose créé par l'entreprise
lonel lonnaise pardon zwing et qui a
fait l'objet d'une étude publiée le 9
juin 2023 dans le New England Journal of
Medicine ce test identifié correctement
96 % des cas d'endométrioses avec moins
de 5 % de faux négatifs alors qu'au
aujourd'hui l'Inserm évalue le délai
d'érance diagnostique à 10 ans la
généralisation d'un tel test permettrait
d'IR rememédier enfin les travaux en
commission ont montré la nécessité
absolue de cette proposition de loi le
groupe lot a reconnu que l'article 1
créerait une exonération spécifique et
totale pour l'endométriose en
particulier en dehors des dispositifs
existants les républicains et je les en
remercie ont poursuivi en indiquant
souscrire totalement à l'article 1 qui
crée un statut d'Al avec une prise en
charge totale par l'assurance maladie
les écologistes ont admis que c'est bien
parce que l'État ne fait pas assez en
matière de santé des femmes que nous
sommes amenés à étudier des textes du
groupe rassemblement national le MoDem a
pour sa part posé la question de savoir
si notre débat ne devrait pas dépasser
ces querelles politiques pour être util
aux femmes en indiquant que poser la
question de l'endométriose dans les
entreprises participe à lever un tabou
enfin Renaissance à affirmer en
commission je cite penseer qu'il faut
s'inscrire dans la durée avec
l'amélioration des diagnostics et
surtout de la prise en charge
chirurgicale pouvant elle-même être
source de complication qui justifie l'AL
c'est précisément l'objet de cette
proposition de loi chers collègu et je
partage les constats des différents
groupes visés je les invite donc à voter
ce texte certes il arrive que
l'endométriose passe inaperçu ou presque
mais lorsque la douleur vous clououit
lorsque vous êtes dans l'incapacité
d'aller au lycée à l'université de
travailler de gérer le quotidien
d'accueillir vos amis ou de mener un
projet parental l'endométriose est un
poison dont la réité largement minimisé
ou niée par la méconnaissance
l'ignorance ou des pensifs paternalistes
obsolètes chers collègues faites preuve
de liberté individuelle et d'objectivité
renoncez le temps de l'étude de ce texte
aux postures politiciennes et prenons
tous ensemble notre part pour soutenir
cette avancée majeure pour les femmes ce
matin une seule option s'offre à nous
faire de ce jeudi 12 octobre la
concrétisation des espoir de millions de
nos concitoyennes j'en appelle donc à la
responsabilité de tous à votre capacité
d' analyse d'avance merci pour elle je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
nous poursuivons avec le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau vous avez la
[Applaudissements]
parole monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les
députés aujourd'hui dans notre pays une
femme sur 10 est touchée à des degrés
divers par
l'endométriose cet enjeu je le connais
bien et je porte ce combat depuis
longtemps je l'ai porté dans mes
précédentes fonctions notamment à la
tête de l'agence régionale de santé
d'Île-de-France et je
continue résolument à m'y engager comme
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention vous avez raison monsieur le
rapporteur ce sujet mérite un débat un
débat de fond un débat politique un
débat tout sauf
technocratique souffrir d'une maladie
gynécologique chronique aux symptômes
très variés et aux manifestations
pouvant être terriblement douloureuses
est avant tout une épreuve intime
l'endométriose ce sont autant
d'histoires de combat individuel que de
patientes qui subissent au quotidien des
douleurs pouvant être invalidantes au
bureau à l'école dans les
transports chacun sait ici par où il est
venu à ce sujet par quel canal ce combat
est devenu le sien et je ne dénie à
personne le droit d'embrasser ce
combat si vous me permettez un mot
personnel c'est par le féminisme que je
suis venu à ce sujet et pour moi il ne
faut jamais oublier que la santé des
femmes est avant tout un droit des
femmes même dans la santé il y a
évidemment des billets de genre oui je
pense que la recherche serait allée
beaucoup plus vite si 2 millions et demi
de nos concitoyens masculins étaient
touchés par des douleurs aussi violentes
ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas une formule de tribune
le fond de ma pensée c'est que la santé
des femmes le droit des femmes la
liberté des femmes à disposer de leur
vie et de leur corps sont un bloc un
bloc inséable on ne pique pas dedans ce
qui vous intéresse ce combat on le prend
en entier ou on ne le prend pas du tout
cela impose de la constance et de la
cohérence je ne vous la dénie pas
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai plus de
doute sur certains de vos collègues de
votre
groupe ce sont
l'endométriose ce sont des
trajectoires personnelles et des projets
parfois contrariés ou tout simplement
brisés je pense notamment à toutes
celles atteintes dans leur désir de
maternité par ce qui constitue la
première cause d'infertilité en France
l'endométriose ce sont des doutes des
questions et de l'incompréhension quand
on sait que l'érrance médicale est
encore en moyenne de 7 ans avec un
diagnostic avant le diagnostic
d'endométrie
on banalise du reste ce terme d'irance
diagnostique l'airance c'est être seul
c'est entendre 100 fois que c'est dans
la tête que ce ne sont rien d'autre que
des règles douloureuses
oui nous devons agir et nous agissons
résolument car car quand certains tabou
persistent certains tabout peuvent
empêcher notamment les jeunes filles
d'en parler à leurs proches quand ces
sujets sont encore insuffisamment pris
en compte dans les différentes sphères
de la société notamment dans le monde
professionnel je sais ce que ça fait de
ne pas savoir ce que l'on a de ne pas
être entendu ou écouter quand on décrit
ses symptômes ou ses séquels j'y
reviendrai peut-être tout à l'heure mais
je sais aussi le soulagement que procure
un diagnostic établit une reconnaissance
enfin une prise en charge l'endométriose
touche vous l'avez dit monsieur le
rapporteur entre 1 millions et demi et 2
millions et demi de nos concitoyennes
c'est donc un sujet de santé publique
c'est un sujet de société c'est un sujet
qui ne concerne pas que les femmes
notamment parce que comme pour bien trop
d'autres problématiques ressenties
relative à la santé gynécologique ou à
la santé des femmes en général cette
souffrance a été trop longtemps
invisibilisée ou
banalisé un enjeu de société et un enjeu
de santé publique disais-je qui appelle
plus qu'une réponse collective une
mobilisation générale de l'ensemble de
la
société cette mobilisation n'a pas
commencé il y a quelques semaines ni
même quelques mois cela fait des années
qu'elle se construit et se
renforce je voudrais commencer par
mentionner le formidable travail mené
par les associations qui ont été de tous
les combats sur tous les fronts parfois
face au silence des
gouvernements grâce à elle grâce à elle
la parole s'est libérée et aujourd'hui
l'endométriose est au même titre que
d'autres pathologies de un enjeu de
politique de santé publique et je le dis
ici en toute humilité je ne sais pas si
sans leur abnégation si sans certain
certaines professionnelles de santé
scientifique engagé à leur côté les
pouvoirs publics auraient agis et réagit
aussi
fortement je sais que vous êtes
également nombreuse et nombreux à porter
haut cet enjeu de par les bandes de cet
hémicycle dans la majorité comme dans
les oppositions la présidente Véronique
rot
Véronique louvagi Marie-Pierre ricin
Sébastien ptavi michaë Boulou Clémentine
Autin tout le travail de la délégation
au droits des femmes à laquelle vous
participez monsieur le rapporteur avec
leurs idées diverses leurs approches
variées les groupes politiques ont eux
aussi contribué à rendre cette
pathologie visible à faire de sa juste
prise en compte l'enjeu politique
qu'elle mérite d'être on ne peut que
saluer la multiplication des initiatives
sur le sujet d'où qu'ell viennent dès
lors qu'elle propose des réponses
correctes et de répondre précisément à
de véritables
problématiques la réponse du
gouvernement c'est quant à elle traduite
dans la stratégie nationale de lutte
contre la l'endométriose il n'y a
monsieur le rapporteur aucune inaction
elle a été lancée par le Président de la
République en janvier 2022 et je crois
je vais en tout cas essayer de vous le
démontrer qu'elle apporte une réponse
collective structurée ambitieuse mais
aussi adaptable aux enjeux et je le dis
aussi très clairement ici cette
stratégie nationale elle est la
stratégie nationale qui est le fruit de
tous les travaux précédents qu'on ne
elle n'a pas vocation pardon d'être
triviale à plier le match elle a
vocation à être adapté aux travaux des
différents des
différentses instances et notamment
parlementaires à laquelle ont contribué
je l'évoqué tout à l'heure la délégation
au droits des femmes à laquelle la la
résolution portée par Clémentine Autin
en 2021 a aussi beaucoup
apporté fruit d'un long travail de
coconstruction avec les professionnels
les associations cette stratégie se
décline sur le long terme avec des
réponses de court terme elle apporte des
réponses structurelles et
opérationnelles j'en présidé mercredi
dernier depuis le CHU de Rennes le
second comité de pilotage avec la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche et la ministre déléguée
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les
hommes ce comité de pilotage mesdames et
messieurs les députés il était poignant
des association de poignant de pardon de
patients la parole libre poignant de
voir tous les professionnels qui sur un
territoire la Bretagne vous l'avez
évoqué se mobilise du médecin
généraliste au meilleurs spécialiste du
CHU en passant par les centres experts
de la douleur ou les kinésithérapeutes
oui la problématique de
l'endométriose soulève des enjeux
d'accès au soins en premier lieu et je
tiens pour indispensable dans la lutte
contre toutes les inégalités de santé de
garantir à toutes une prise en charge
adaptée et ce et cela passe notamment
par la reconnaissance des particularités
et des vulnérabilités spécifiques
auxquelles font face les femmes c'est
pour cela que la stratégie porte
l'objectif de donner accès à un
diagnostic rapide et à des soins de
qualité sur l'ensemble du
territoire cela passe par la
structuration dans chaque région d'une
filière dédiée à la prise en charge
graduée de l'endométriose s'intégrant
aux organisations et au dispositifs de
coordination
préexistants je suis personnellement
l'avancée de cette structuration des
filières cinq régions France
métropolitaine sont déjà dites en stade
avancé avec une filière en cours de
finalisation ou finalisé car vous l'avez
dit monsieur le rapporteur la réponse
sur le territoire j'y reviendrai est
encore trop hétérogène à Rennes la
semaine dernière j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir de manière approfondie avec
les professionnels du réseau breton les
associations locales et nationales et
certaines patientes qui sont impliqué
dans cette démarche tous toutes
reconnaissez que le cadre fourni par la
filière et les moyens qui lu sont
alloués permettent de fédérer à
certaines conditions sur lesquelles je
vais revenir aussi toutes les bonnes
volontés pour proposer des parcours de
soins exhaustifs adaptés et innovants
aux femmes qui en ont
besoin la formation des soignant est au
cœur du projet porté par le par les
réseaux et par le gouvernement nous
avons fait des progrès au niveau
national en ce sens avec l'entrée de la
pathologie dans le programme de du 2e
cycle de formation des médecins ou son
inscription dans les orientations
prioritaires de DPC mais les filières
ont aussi tout leur rôle à jouer ce
sujet il est central celui de la
formation mais aussi de la formation
continue plusieurs amendements notamment
du groupe LR y reviennent mais je ne
pense pas que ce soit la loi qui soit le
bon véhicule pour les faire avancer même
si j'en partage le fond je le dis très
simplement aujourd'hui la mobilisation
notamment de l'assurance maladie avec
avec des des webinaires notamment et des
formations dédiées à chaque
médecin avec des formations dédiées pour
chaque médecin va faire progresser plus
que le fait d'avoir fait 3 mois de
formation sur l'endométriose au tout
début de ces études cela concerne les
médecins bien sûr mais également tous
les professionnels pouvant intervenir
dans le parcours des patientes je pense
notamment aux kinésithérapeutes qui
peuvent acquérir certains gestes
spécifiques pour soulager les patientes
mais qui ne peuvent pas s'ils n'ont pas
été formés à cela cela ce ce comité de
pilotage m'a conforté dans la certitude
que cette démarche est la bonne pour
cela et afin d'accélérer cette dynamique
j'ai fixé l'objectif dans une
instruction que j'ai adressé à
l'assurance maladie et à l'ensemble des
ARS que l'identification des filières
soit achevée dans l'ensemble des régions
d'ici à la fin de l'année ensuite et en
matière de recherche car l'endométriose
est aussi un enjeu scientifique mesdames
et et Messieurs les Députés ce ne sont
pas moins de 30 millions d'euros qui
sont consacrés à un programme
prioritaire de recherche piloté par
l'incerme intitulé santé des femmes et
santé des couples j'insiste sur ce
montant car cela représente 10 millions
de plus que dans la que dans la
stratégie initialement prévu en 2022
parce que nous l'avons adapté suite au
débat et alors même que le programme a
été recentré autour de deux axes
intimement liés que sont évidemment
l'endométriose et notamment c'est
déterminant et mais aussi l'infertilité
que vous avez cité monsieur le
rapporteur le comité de pilotage a été
l'occasion de présenter pour la première
fois après plus d'un an de travaux ce
programme finalisé qui comprend
notamment un projet épidémiologique
ciblé sur l'endométriose un projet
unique au monde et qui entre désormais
dans sa phase opérationnelle je souhaite
avec Sylvie rotaillot que la France soit
aux avant-postes sur la recherche dans
ce domaine mais
finalement et c'est le dernier notre
stratégie c'est la bataille de
pardon c'est la bataille de
l'information et de la communication
qu'il faut continuer à mener et au fond
peut-être est-ce d'elle que tout découle
c'est un travail de fond et sans
remettre en cause les efforts déjà
fournis je suis conscient qu'il faut
aller plus loin et là et là aussi
certains des propositions qui ont été
fixées ou des orientations qui ont été
des fixés devront être suivis de très
près je pense notamment à des
propositions et des amendements qui ont
été qui sont portés par les républicains
et qui portent sur l'éducation nationale
nationale sur tous ces sujets mais aussi
en matière d'information des personnes
concernées il nous faut aller plus loin
et y aller plus vite c'est précisément
le sens de l'instruction que j'ai signé
il y a quelques semaines en l'adressant
je vous l'ai dit à mes directeurs
d'administration centrale aux ARS et
d'ors et déjà cette instruction a permis
d'approfond ondir certains points de la
stratégie d' d'enclencher de nouvelles
actions je vous entendais sourire à ma
droite quand j'évoquais les webinaire
nous n'aurions pas tenu pendant le covid
si les les médecins n'avaient pas été
formés et eu accès à ces ressources de
formation je vous invite à aller
regarder le webinaire relatif à
l'endométriose vous verrez combien en
quelques dizaines de minutes on est
capable de donner de fournir d'apporter
au médecins les premiers réflexes les
bons réflexes qui font qu'à l'issue de
ult ation médicale une femme ne sortira
pas en se disant en sayant séant entendu
dire une fois de plus que c'est sans
doute dans sa tête et qu'un dolipran
devrait faire l'affaire face à des
règles
douloureuses cette instruction permet
ainsi d'approfondir d'approfondir notre
réponse en matière de reconnaissance en
al de l'endométriose qui qui est l'un
des sujets qui nous préoccupe
particulièrement
aujourd'hui et je m'attarderai quelques
instants ici sur ce sujet de la de de la
reconnaissance d'affection en longue
durée en en précisant tout d'abord que
l'affection à long en longue durée et
peut-être que ce débat peut avoir lieu
n'est pas une reconnaissance d'une
maladie à proprement parler elle est
d'abord la prise en charge du recours
spécifique au système de soins
spécifique intense et donc cher pour les
patientes au système de soins et qui est
prise en charge à 100 % par l'assurance
maladie vous l'avez dit compris sur le
jour de carence ou les transports l'AL
31 qui a été souvent évoqué n'est pas un
moins 10 an par rapport à la liste de
l'affection de longue durée dite 30 bien
au contraire c'est une forme d'affection
de longue durée différente qui ouvre les
mêmes droits qui est plus adapté au
maladie comme l'endométriose la laal 31
elle est elle estap elle est accordée en
fonction de l'examen individuel du
protocole de soins de chaque patiente la
ld30 elle repose sur une liste de
pathologies dont les formes éligibles
sont définies par des critères stricts
et
limitatifs inscrire l'endométriose en
al30 supposerait donc la définition par
la Haute Autorité de santé de ces
critères médicaux
d'admission spécifiques qui vont être et
qui serait extrêmement difficile à
établir pour une maladie qui comme vous
le savez peut avoir des formes
asymptommatiques on peut avoir des
atteintes profondes des tissus et des
organes qui sont asymptommatiques on
peut avoir des formes violentes et
douloureuses qui ne se manifeste
cliniquement que par des lésions
superficielles l'endométriose c'est cela
notamment pour celle des pour celles
dont les symptômes de la maladie ne
correspondrai pas exactement aux
critères et qui seraient alors pris qui
seraiit alors exclus de toute prise en
charge au titre de
l'AL une fois cela clarifié si grâce au
dispositif de l'ALD 31 les formes graves
et invalidantes de la maladie pe
pouvaient être pris en charge toutes les
femmes qui pourraient avoir accès n'y
aurait pas recours c'est aussi cela et
n'y ont pas recours d'ors et déjà vous
l'avez dit le chiffre de 15000 est
insuffisant il a progressé de 43 % en
non an il a été multiplié par 3 donc le
combat c'est que les professionnels de
santé soit préparé formés à prendre en
charge ces sujets-là c'est tout le sens
de la stratégie que porte le
gouvernement soit parce qu'elles sont en
situation d'érance diagnostique ou
thérapeutique soit parce que parfois
elles n'ont même pas connaissance de
leurs droits les patientes ne savent pas
qu'elles peuvent être reconnues en
infection de longue durée l'instruction
très claire que j'ai donné et de
travailler à cet enjeu sous toutes ses
facettes l'assuranceange l'assurance
maladie a déjà ainsi rédigé en lien avec
les associations une nouvelle circulaire
spécifique sur l'endométriose afin
d'actualiser et d'harmoniser les
principes directeurs utilisés pour
l'évaluation des reconnaissances en
al c'est un travail qui est déjà très
avancé et sachez-le c'est comme cela que
ça fonctionne dansre pays on peut sans
peut-être de temps en temps trouver ça
extrêmement lourd mais oui les médecins
attendent d'être nourris accompagnés
formés tout au long de leur carrière
pour savoir comment prendre en charge
mieux prendre en charge certaines
pathologie j'ai également demandé à mes
services de me proposer avant la fin de
l'année pour les patientes ne relevant
pas du dispositif d'Al de nouvelles
actions pourant être mise en place afin
de maîtriser le reste à charge relatif à
la prise en charge et au traitement de
l'endométriose en lien avec les
associations de patientes mobilisées sur
ce sujet je crois monsieur le rapporteur
que vous avez très peu mentionné ces
association voire pas du tout je pense
que cette explication sur laald bien
qu'un peu laborieuse était nécessaire
parce qu'elle a notamment dans votre
commission cristalliser les débats et je
pense qu'il ne faut pas confondre ce
débat sur
l'AL avec celui sur la reconnaissance de
la maladie et permettez-moi un instant
de revenir
là-dessus
je veux le dire quel que soit son niveau
de gravité que l'on ait recours à la Ld
ou pas il y a un besoin de mettre de
mettre un mot sur sa maladie se
l'entendre dire oui l'endométriose est
une vraie maladie cela reste encore une
forme d'angle mort et nous devrons
trouver les moyens de donner à toutes
ces femmes cette reconnaissance elles en
ont besoin ce n'est pas un sujet
accessoire j'hésite à le dire ici
il y a
comme il y a comme un caractère
dérisoire à parler de soi mais et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur c'est
bien aussi de l'intime dont on
parle j'ai été il y a quelques années
victime d'une maladie neurologique dont
toute la littérature disait qu'elle
n'avait aucune
séquelle depuis chaque jour dans la
jambe droite j'ai des picotements des
fourmillements certains jours
insupportables la
littérature continuit pendant longtemps
de dire que ce syndrome aigu ne devait
rien àoir ne devait rien laisser un jour
en tant que dgds je suis allé dans un
congrès où un médecin a pour la première
fois exposé que selon ses
recherches tous les syndromes de
guilinbaret pour citer cette pathologie
laissit des c'est
quel ce jour-là pardon de le dire ainsi
et il n'y a pas ici des faits de tribune
ce jour-là ma seule réaction a été de
pleurer de pleurer parce que ça voulait
dire que ces douleurs dans la jambe ce
n'était pas des douleurs dans ma tête
uniquement je mesure que les mots le
fait de reconnaître une maladie ont
quelquefois autant de force que la
douleur et je pense que nous avons
devant nous un travail pour les pour les
femmes pour les malades qui même si leur
endométriose ont des formes légères ou
des symptômes légers ont besoin de
s'entendre dire qu'elles sont malades et
qu'on doit les prendre en
charge mesdames et messieurs les députés
je suis bien conscient que tout n'est
pas encore parfait qu'il reste du
travail et nous devons tous nous
mobiliser le texte qui est proposé
aujourd'hui à votre examen se veut être
une réponse et je crois à sa sincérité
toutefois tant sur le fond des solutions
proposées que sur la forme de cette
ative cette proposition de loi me semble
ni tenable ni opportune en s'arimant à
une noble cause ce texte opportuniste
venant d'un groupe qui a de multiples
occasions appr prouvver sa
méconnaissance des enjeux d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes démontre
cette fois-ci en plus une méconnaissance
autant du droit que de la maladie j'ai
eu l'occasion de le mentionner à
plusieurs reprises et quiconque connaît
un temps soit peu le sujet c'est que
l'endométrie est une maladie complexe
qui affecte différemment chaque femme
qui en souffle en souffre c'est pour ça
que créer une exonération spécifique et
totale pour l'endométriose hors du cadre
de l'AL n'est ni juridiquement ni ni
tenable ni opportun et j'ai déjà
expliqué pour la pourquoi la réform la
réponse actuelle qui doit progresser est
appropriée systématiser la
reconnaissance en qualité de
travailleuse handicapé pour cause
d'endométriose n'est pas non plus une
réponse adaptée les textes actuels les
textes actuels permettent déjà
d'attribuer une reconnaissance de
travailleurs handicapés aux personnes
atteintes d'endométriose et qui en ont
besoin non pas au titre du diagnostic
d'endométriose mais au titre d'un degré
de limitation concrète causé par la
maladie mais plus profondément la
distinction entre la maladie et le
handicap est l'un des fondements de
notre politique en la matière reconnu et
salué d'ailleurs par les personnes
directement concernées je veux
d'ailleurs souligner que le nombre de
femmes bénéficiant de l'ALD est en
constante augmentation et je suis prêt
dans les mois qui viennent à venir
devant nous rendre compte de
l'augmentation de ces chiffres c'est
pourquoi je vous invite à rejeter ce
texte dont la rédaction est en total
décalage avec les attentes et les
[Applaudissements]
besoins est-ce un rejet par principe
parce que inititive vient du
rassemblement national
non le sujet de la santé des femmes et
plus largement la défense des droits des
femmes n'est le monopole de personne
mais ce n'est en aucun cas une raison
pour faire pour dire ou pour voter ce
qui vous plaît dans le droit des femmes
ce que vous jugez nécessaire quand vous
êtes contre la reconnaissance
constitutionnelle de l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse
chers collègues ch collègues laissz le
ministre terminé manière c'est une
manière pour vous
d'essayer que la partie cache le tout
mais cette proposition de loi ne sera
pas votre cap d'invisibilité par rapport
à votre vision des femmes dans la
société est-ce que présenter dans les
mêmes termes par la majorité ce texte
aurait été soutenu par le gouvernement
non toujours pas parce que les
dispositifs proposés ne sont simplement
pas les bons et on finit par se demander
au fond car vous êtes trop fin notamment
monsieur le rapporteur pour ne pas le
savoir si vous ne le savez pas
pertinemment mais préférez tenter cette
OPA pour de mauvaises raison mais je
vous donne acte d'un point votre texte
permet de clarifier les termes du débat
de prendre le temps d'évoquer un sujet
majeur de santé publique le prendre le
temps de s'interroger sur le fond de
vous présenter le bilan de stratégie qui
peut-être serait resté dans des cercles
plus restreints je ne ni pas que de
nombreux chantiers doivent être
approfondis mais je veux vous dire que
vous pouvez compter sur l'engagement de
de du ministère de la Santé du ministère
de la recherche dans toutes leurs
composantes avec l'appui de l'ensemble
des forces par l'ensemble des forces
parlementaires pour engager ce combat
c'est un combat de progrès et je le
porterai jusqu'à son terme je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre nous ouvrons
la discussion générale avec un
intervenant pour chaque groupe politique
pour 10 minutes maximum et pour le
rassemblement national Madame Michelle
[Applaudissements]
Martinez monsieur le président prident
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues comme vous le
voyez monsieur le ministre c'est une
femme qui défend l'endométrisome une
femme qui connaî bien la maladie
puisquelle en a souffert pendant des
années donc au rassemblement national on
défend aussi le droit des
femmes l'endométriose est la première
cause d'infertilité en France c'est une
c'est une maladie gynécologique
inflammatoire chronique qui se
caractérise par la présence d'endomètre
une muqueuse utérine en dehors de
l'utérus cette pathologie est évolutive
et tous les organes peuvent être
touchés intestin estomac rectome Vess
vagin système neuropathique et dans le
plus rares cas les poumons les yeux et
le cerveau cette maladie est
caractérisée par de multiples symptômes
malaise trouble digestif fatigue
chronique mais le principal d'entre eux
c'est la douleur douleurs abdominales
douleurs lombaires douleurs
neuropathiques elles peuvent toutes
intervenir pendant comme en dehors du
cycle menstruel et elles impactent la
vie de millions de nos
concitoyennes l'impact de cette maladie
sur la vie privé social est important
risque d'infertilité isolement devoir
faire face à l'incompréhension d'un
entourage qui ne connaî pas ou mal
l'endométriose toutes ces épreuves
peuvent entraîner des problèmes de santé
mentales tels que la dépression car si
les douleurs physique surviennent
principalement lors de crise les
douleurs psychiques lié au
questionnements au études sont-elles
profondes et permanentes les
répercussions sur la vie scolaire et
professionnelle de ces jeunes filles et
femmes sont tout aussi désastreus
absentéisme difficulté à garder un
emploi ou à suivre un cursus
scolaire toutes ces maladies dans tous
les domaines de la vie en font une
maladie
handicapante en France nous sommes près
de 2 millions de femmes à être touché
par ce mal soit près de 10 % d'entre
nous cet hémicycle compte 215 15 femmes
sur ces bancs ce qui signifie que très
probablement une vingtaine d'entre nous
font face ou ont dû faire face à cette
pathologie il est très souvent dit qu'il
existe une endométriose pour chaque
femme touchée il s'agit là d'une vérité
puisque la pluralité des symptômes et
les différentes manifestations de ces
derniers varient de cas en cas ce qui
rend difficile le diagnostique qui met
en moyenne entre 7 et 10 ans avant
d'être posé selon
l'incerne cette errance médicale est
souvent liée au manque de formation de
nos médecins mais plus globalement des
professionnels de santé dans l'ensemble
dont font partie les infirmiers
scolaires par exemple et évidemment
comment ne pas évoquer la
désertification médicale de notre pays
qui n'épargne pas la
gynécologie selon le rapport
d'information de la délégation des
droits des femmes au Sénat du 14 octobre
2029 21 excusez-moi près de 80 % des
départements français au moins de trois
gynécologues médicaux pour 100000 femmes
et 13 départements en sont même
dépourvus selon l'fq que choisir un
quart des Français un quart des
Françaises n'ont d'ailleurs pas accès à
des soins gynécologiques pourtant
essentiel dans la vie de chaque femme le
vieil àâge qui veut que ce soit normal
d'avoir mal pendant les règles ne
participe pas non plus à la prévention
et au dépistage de cette maladie qui
commence pour la plupart des femmes
atteintes à avant 20 ans une période de
la vie où l'on se
construit du fait du caractère évolutif
du mal de la maladie de nombreux examens
sont nécessaires pour son diagnostic et
son suivi échographie endopelvienne IRM
célioscopie autant d'actes qui coûte
cher qui ne sont pas remboursés en
totalité par la Sécurité
Sociale la prise en charge de ces frais
médicaux à 100% de par son entrée dans
les pathologies considérées comme
affection longue durée serait donc une
avancée
importante quant à la reconnaissance de
la qualité de travailleurs handicapés
celle-ci protégerait les femmes en leur
permettant d'avoir un poste de travail
adapté de bénéficier d'horair aménagés
et de doubler la durée du préavis
légal contrairement à tout ce que l'on a
pu entendre lors d'un débat en
commission le statut de RQTH n'engendre
pas de frais supplémentaires ou
l'impossibilité d'obtenir un prê
bancaire en effet depuis le 1er juin
2022 il n'est plus nécessaire de remplir
de questionnaires sur son état de santé
si la part assurée par personne est
inférieure ou égale à 200000 € et si le
remboursement du du prêt est prévu avant
les 60 ans de
l'intéressé enfin chers collègues notre
proposition est loin d'être
opportuniste la prise de conscience de
notre famille politique sur ce sujet ne
date pas d'hier ni
d'avanttiier la reconnaissance de
l'endométriose était un engagement
présidentielle majeur de Marine Le Pen
envers les femmes comme dans sa lettre
française du 7 mars 2022 les travaux du
rassemblement national à ce sujet sont
nombreux à commencé par la proposition
de résolution au Parlement européen de
notre collègue Marie duchi qui visait à
reconnaître cette maladie pas seulement
pour les françaises mais pour toutes les
européennes à toutes fins utiles je
rappelle que cette proposition qui a
d'abord été validée par la présidence du
Parlement européen n'a jamais été
examiné en commission suite au lâche
refus du président de cette dernière
votre collègue macroniste Pascal
canampfin cette proposition de loi
déposée par Monsieur Tangi n'est pas une
redite de la résolution du 13 janvier
2022 ne vous en déplaise collègue de
gauche elle vient seulement au soutien
de celle qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité
en janvier
2022 car en effet Monsieur Verant à
l'époque ministre de la Santé avait
promis une grande stratégie nationale de
lutte et de prévention mais aujourd'hui
nous en sommes toujours au même point
encore une fois le gouvernement aurait
excellé en coup de com mais pas dans la
concrétisation des promesses faites les
recherches sur les causes de cette
maladie pthoge quant à celle de
l'élaboration d'un traitement elles
sembl encore bien loin il est temps de
prendre vos responsabilités il est temps
de mettre en action vos engagements il
est temps d'enfin le calvaire que vivent
ces françaises vous le leur
devez le groupe rassemblement national
défend les droits des femmes et
continuera à le faire c'est pourquoi je
vous invite tous chers collègues à voter
en faveur de cette proposition de loi je
vous
remercie merci madame la
députée nous poursuivons pour le groupe
la France insoumise et pour 5 minutes
madame Clémentine
atin
mes chers collègues combien de temps
combien de temps
encore les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose devrai attendre en
moyenne 7 7 ans avant d'obtenir un
diagnostic médical combien de
rendez-vous a s'entendre dire que c'est
dans la tête que les règles ça fait mal
qu'il n'y a rien d'anormal à souffrir
d'un rapport sexuel un doliprane et ça
passe
et de rentrer chez elle sans aucun suivi
médical sans accompagnement pour
accélérer le diagnostic par manque de
formation d'accès à des parcours de
soins structurés organisés sur tout le
territoire combien de temps encore
allons-nous expliquer aux adolescent que
souffrir en silence c'est normal quand
on est une femme alors que personne ne
compte ici ni nulle part d'ailleurs sur
le rassemblement national pour apporter
des réponses aux légitimes besoins des
femmes pour pour
s'émanciper nous sommes là de fan ce qui
s'appelle un écran de fumée oui le
Rassemblement National veut par cette
proposition installer un écran de fumée
sur son histoire sur ses valeurs sur son
programme qui s'oppose à la liberté des
femmes dit autrement dit autrement si le
parti de Marine Le Pen fait mine
aujourd'hui de s'occuper de
l'endométriose c'est pour mieux
camoufler son projet fondamentalement
opposé aux droits des femmes
et je me souviens et je me souviens de
votre absence de votre absence de votre
silence quand iciè ici même nous avons
voté en 2022 à l'unanimité à mon
initiative au nom de mon groupe
parlementaire un texte pour que cette
maladie qui touche près de 2 millions de
femmes en France entre dans la liste des
affections longue durée dite à
LD3 le rassemblement national c'est le
refus d'inscrire VG dans la Constitution
et d'allonger le délai de 12 à 14
semaines l'une de vos députés ici sur
ces bancs compare même l'IVG à un
génocide pendant que d'autres n'ont que
le mot IVG de confort à la bouche et
propose de le dérembourser le
rassemblement national c'est le refus de
condamner la Pologne qui a rendu le
droit à l'avortement quasiment
inaccessible ce que veut le
rassemblement national c'est la fin du
ministère dédié au droit des femmes
chers collègues
chers cèg madametin a encore 2 minutes
30 2 minutes 25 elle va les utiliser
allez-y madame otin un petit vous avez
vos 2 minutes 25 vous pouvez
continuer je sais ça vous dérange qu'on
vous rappelle tout cela alors que nous
ne sommes pas surpris de découvrir ici
une proposition de loi qui n'est ni fait
ni affaire qui ne correspond ni au
besoins des femmes ni aux attentes des
associations cette proposition de loi ne
porte pas l'inscription de la maladie
dans la liste des affections longue
duréelle des 30 qui permettraiit
l'exonération du ticket modérateur et
cela automatiquement dès la confirmation
du diagnostic le procédé légistique en
est une très mauvaise copie de notre
proposition à nous avec la création d'un
nouveau statut d'affection longue durée
pour l'endométriose ajouter à l'accès au
statut de travailleuse handicapé c'est
même à un Mo- 10 ans à un moins 10 ans
que cette proposition pourrait aboutir
en matière d'arrêt de travail et
pourtant il y a urgence il y a urgence
parce que c'est c'est un santé c'est un
enjeu majeur de santé publique et de
droits des femmes si le rassemblement
national peut déposer aujourd'hui cette
proposition de loi c'est parce que le
gouvernement n'a pas appliqué le vote
unanime de l'Assemblée nationale il a
donc ouvert une brèche et c'est dans
cette brèche que le rassemblement
national s'est engouvré c'est un mépris
je le dis sincèrement c'est vraiment un
mépris de haute volée pour les députés y
compris celles et ceux de renaissance
qui avaient soutenu cette volonté d'un
véritable pas en avant dans la prise en
charge de l'endométriose la demande
était pourtant simple et claire inscrire
l'endométriose par un décret pris par le
gouvernement puisqu'on peut pas faire
autrement dans la liste al des 30 pas
possible trop compliqué nous ditons car
la maladie ayant des pathologies
diverses qui est vrai on ne saurait pas
comment l'inscrire dans cette liste
puisque passer par la Ld 31 comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui ne répond pas au
besoins je vous demande monsieur le
ministre si c'est si compliqué pourquoi
ne pas créer une autre liste taillée sur
mesure pour la santé des femmes les
arguments
technocratiques ne sont pas une réponse
pour les femmes qui attendent en
souffrant mon impression et je sais que
je suis loin d'être la seule à l'avir
c'est que le refus de faire entrer
l'endométriose dans les ailes des 30
c'est en fait un problème de dépense
publique c'est pour ne pas dépenser plus
c'est pour contenir la dépense publique
sur le dos des femmes et vous nous
répondez que vous avez une stratégie
nationale mais voilà tout ce que l'on
trouve pas dans votre stratégie
nationale des moyens conséquents pour
favoriser la recherche diminuer les
délis diagnosti améliorer la formation
des personnels et diminuer les
inégalités territoriales de prise en
charge alors si cette proposition de loi
du rassemblement national n'a aucun sens
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce qui vous
empêche d'en mettre en
re merci merci madame la députée et
bonjour à vous aussi pour les
républicains et pour 5 minutes madame
Isabelle valent
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues en
France l'endométriose touche 2 millions
de femmes en âge de procréer soit une
femme sur soit une femme sur 10 comme ma
collègue madame Martinez j'ai moi aussi
été touché par cette affection
pathologique mais qu'est-ce que
l'endométriose quels en sont les
conséquences concrètes sur le quotidien
de ces femmes touchées dans leur
féminité comment l'appréendentt-on sur
le plan médical autant de questions
absentes du débat public cette
proposition de loi portée par nos
collègues du rassemblement national nous
donne aujourd'hui l'opportunité de nous
en saisir l'endométriose est une
affection géncologique fréquente et
complexe qui perturbe le bien-être
physique des femmes qui peut engendrer
des conséquences psychologiques parfois
lourde et avoir des répercussions sur
leur vie
intime cette pathologie est une source
de douleur chronique et
d'infertilité cela a été dit chaque cas
est différent chaque histoire est
différente dans notre pays en 2023 les
femmes sont confronté à un retard de
diagnostic quasi systématique qui est en
moyenne de 7 ans durant lesqueles
l'érance médicale est une source de
souffrance
supplémentaire un diagnostic précoce et
des soins adaptés soulage grandement
toutes ces femmes face à ces constats
une stratégie nationale de lutte contre
la maladie a été souhaitée en février
2022 par Olivier verrant à leur ministre
de la Santé dans le dessin d'améliorer
la la détection de la maladie en amont
et la prise en charge
ultérieure la création de filière
territoriale ad doosssé à des centres de
référence pour améliorer la prise en
charge de qualité des femmes tant sur le
plan diagnostique que thérapeutique une
amélioration de la détection de
l'endométriose par les médecins de santé
Scola libéraux et radiologu une
meilleure prise en charge de la douleur
mais à ce jour rien de concret sur les
territoires l'accompagnement
psychologique des femmes et la
reconnaissance du caractère invalidant
de cette pathologie demeure l'angle mort
de nos politiques de santé publique
pourtant la parole des femmes se libère
pour témoigner chaque jour du handicap
vécu il existe actuellement deux listes
à ld30 et à LD 31 qui peuvent ouvrir des
droits aux personnes atteintes de
maladie la première permet une prise en
charge à 100 % sans avance de frais et
la suppression des jours de carence dès
le 2è arrêt la deuxème sur laquelle
figure l'endométriose peut permettre
d'accéder à ses droits mais le statut
est beaucoup plus difficile à obtenir
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
propose de revenir sur ces difficultés
et d'accorder à toutes les femmes
atteintes de cette pathologie un statut
d'affection longue durée exonérante avec
une prise en charge totale des soins une
mesure évidemment à laquelle nous
souscrivons pleinement quant à son
article 2 le statut de travailleur
handicapé ce dernier est réputé
satisfait car le dispositif existe déjà
pour les formes les plus graves de la
maladie le premier objectif doit donc
être celui de freiner la progression et
l'aggravation de la maladie et de
soulager les femmes dans leur vie
quotidienne à l'école comme au travail
les républicains sont depuis de
nombreuses années porteurs de
proposition en ce sens en juillet 2020
mes collègues Emmanuel Antoine et
Stéphane vir ont porté une proposition
de de loi pour faire de l'endométriose
une grande cause nationale fin juin
Véronique louvadi propose un meilleur
encadrement législatif pour la
prévention de
l'endométriose si toutes les mesures
contenues dans la proposition de nos
collègues du rassemblement national ne
paraissent pas opportune son vote
enverrait quand même un signal d'espoir
les républicains proposent des
modification substantielle pour
faciliter l'accès au télétravail
permettre d'étendre la sensibilisation à
l'
et faciliter les absences en cours pour
les jeunes filles
scolarisées nous demandons également que
soit prévu dans le cursus de première
année d'études en médecine un programme
sur l'endométriose ce sera certainement
beaucoup plus efficace que les webinaire
nous souhaiterions une grande campagne
de communication qui soit lancée à
l'échelle nationale le but étant que
l'ensemble de la population comme le
corps médical soit
sensibilisé alors mes chers collègues la
santé des femmes ne doit pas rester un
tabou sociétal il est de notre
responsabilité de voter des mesures
qu'elles
attendent l'intérêt de ce texte est de
faire reconnaître l'endométriose comme
une affection de longue durée et de vous
contraindre monsieur le ministre à agir
concrètement pour les 2 millions de
femmes touchées par cette
pathologie ainsi sous réserve des
améliorations prop proposé les
républicains voteront donc ce texte du
rassemblement national monsieur le
ministre de la
Santé la politique politicienne n'
définitivement pas sa place en matière
de santé publique je vous en
remercie merci madame la
députée 5 minutes pour le groupe
démocrate avec Madame Sandrine
[Applaudissements]
Joss merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
ministreadame président de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur chers
collègues il y a bientôt 2 ans le
gouvernement mettait en place sa
stratégie de lutte contre
l'endométriose
recherche diagnostic sensibilisation ont
été définis comme des axes
prioritaires aujourd'hui les
associations ont dressé un bilan plutôt
positif de ce plan qui vise 2 millions
de
femmes 2 millions de femmes
qui survivent face à des saillements des
kyes des inflammations des douleurs
durant leur règles des souffrances
durant leur rapport sexuel
l'endométriose empêche ces femes de
travailler les couples du monde
extérieur jusqu'à parfois les rendre
infertiles
entendons ces femmes qui nous parle je
cite de leur cri du ventre et de ce mal
qui les
pour un sujet si sérieux pour ces 2
millions de femmes qui souffrent le
rassemblement national a osé dans
l'article 1 nier la singularité de cette
maladie il
voudrait
standardiser là où il faut
personnaliser autant de femmes autant de
formes différentes
d'endométriose l'article de
maintenant là encore on
assimile on généralise on ne les écoute
pas et je le répète autant de femmes
autant de formes différentes
d'endométriose en commission j'avais
fait part de la nécessité de prendre en
compte l'impact de cette maladie sur la
santé mentale des femmes au cours de
cette année nous avons pu étudier à de
nombreuses reprises notamment dans la
délégation des droits des femmes c'est
la situation critique de la santé
mentale de ces dernières je remercie
d'ailleurs au passage mes deux collègues
Anne Cécile violent et Pascal Martin
pour leur excellent rapport à ce
sujet et au moment même où pour la
première fois en cette rentrée politique
un parti a l'opportunité de renforcer la
stratégie du gouvernement sur la santé
mentale le rassemblement ne le fait pas
ainsi nous pouvons nous interroger sur
le but de cette proposition de loi qui
n'apporte
rien c'est pour cette raison que le
groupe démocrate réaffirme son soutien à
la stratégie endométriose du
gouvernement et se
positionne pour le renforcement écoutez
bien de la prise en compte de la santé
mental de ces femmes qui souffrent de
cette maladie chers collègues vous
comprendrez que nous voterons contre
cette loi
qui
malheureusement utilise cette pathologie
à des fins
politiques merci madame la députée chers
collègues nous avons jusqu'à minuit
ensemble donc gardez un peu de cette
belle énergie pour écouter pour le
groupe social ant 5 minutes madame Marie
Noë
bstel
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues il y a bientôt 2 ans
l'Assemblée nationale votait à
l'unanimité une proposition de
résolution portée par notre collègue
clémentine auain et Cigné par nombre
d'entre nous cette proposition réclamé
au
gouvernement la reconnaissance de
l'endométriose comme une affection de
longue durée afin de
garantir justice sociale pour toutes les
femmes concernées et une vraie prise en
charge à celles qui attendent parfois
des années cette
reconnaissance mais le gouvernement a
choisi les groupes de travail sans
qu'aucune mesure concrète n'ait été
prise à ce stade pour venir reconnaître
cette maladie et les 4 millions de
femmes qui en souffrent et aujourd'hui
ce sont les mêmes ce sont ces mêmes
femmes qui après l'inertie du
gouvernement font face à la récupération
politique du rassembl
nation car oui cette proposition de loi
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui si
bancale soit-elle n'est qu'un grotex
prétexte pour tenter de masquer vos
habituelles positions
antiféministes toutes les associations
féministes dénoncé en 2022 l'extrême
droite a une constance celle de nous
combattre de nous mépriser de nous
pétiner
disait-elleuis les prop de présidente en
2012 qui déclarait le progrès c'est de
permettre aux femmes de rester à la
maison votre discours envers les femmes
bien loin d'une logique émancipatrice ne
va que dans un
sens vous avez d'ailleurs été de tout
temps l'un des principaux opposants à
l'avortement vous avez régulièrement
dénoncé les soi-disant IVG de confort et
vous êtes fermement opposé à
l'allongement des délais de 12 à 14
semaines et je souviens très bien des
débats je regarde le rapporteur si vous
permettez c'est lui qui dépose le texte
continuez madame la députée je me
souviens très bien des débat car j'étais
corapporteur de cette
proposition à l'Assemblée nationale
comme au Parlement européen Vous vous
opposez quasiment systématiquement au
textes qui promeuvent l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes que ce soit
pour la parité ou pour l'égalité
salariale ou pour l'éducation à la vie
affective et sexuelle à l'école primaire
alors non avec ce texte vous ne trompez
personne et vous ne nous tromperez pas
non plus sur votre soi-disant intention
d'accorder un statut aux femmes
atteintes d'endométriose alors que vous
le savez pertinemment seul un décret
peut avoir des droits cessz de faire
croire le
contraire nous le répétons ici il n'y a
que l'inscription sur la liste des AL 30
la liste des 30 affections de longue
durée exonérante qui permettent au aux
femmes atteintes de ces maladies de
bénéficier du droit à exénération du
ticket modérateur pour tous les actes en
rapport avec elle avec une prise en
charge à 100 % des dépenses liées à ses
soins et traitement et seul un décret
pris par le gouvernement peut inscrire
l'endométriose sur la liste des
AL3 ce n'est ni cette proposition de loi
d'affichage opportuniste ni même la
reconnaissance de statut de travailleur
handicapé qui est stigmatisant ce n'est
pas non plus monsieur le ministre une
simple instruction ministérielle ou
encore des recommandations de bonnes
pratiques qui permettront une réelle
reconnaissance de ces femmes cela
contribue il est vrai à la
reconnaissance de la maladie mais c'est
tout simplement et uniquement un décret
celui que nous réclamons depuis
maintenant 2 ans celui que plus de 4
millions de femmes attendent depuis plus
longtemps encore qui permet mettra une
vraie prise en charge je ne surprendrai
donc personne en indiquant que notre
groupe ne votera pas ce texte
d'affichage merci madame la députée nous
poursuivons s'il vous plaît dans le
silence avec 5 minutes pour le groupe
horizon et Monsieur Frédéric
Valtou monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la journée qui démarre
n'est résolument pas une journée pour
les français ce n'est pas une journée
pour améliorer leur quotidien pour nous
permettre de faire avancer concrètement
de vrais sujets pour nos compatriotes oh
que non c'est une journée pensée par le
groupe rassemblement national pour
tenter des coups des petits coups
tactiques pour tenter de retenir l'
tention sur des postures présentées
comme constructives mais qui au final
débouche sur des textes tellement mal
travaill
qu'ils sont totalement inutiles
chersèèg de vrais sujets transformés en
texte vide de sens voilà la magie du
rassemblement national voilà ce que nous
avons au menu de cette journée que vous
nous avez concocté et c'est dommage et
c'est dommage car ici nous discutons de
la loi de l'écriture juridique des
choses mais passer du slogan et de la
posture à des rédactions utiles
travailler et réaliste et visiblement un
exercice dans lequel pour les députés du
rassemblement national il y a encore de
sac progrès à faire cette proposition
loi en est l'illustration une vraie
cause l'endométriose et la douleur des
femmes qui en souffre une maladie
complexe et douloureuse mais une réponse
qui qui rate totalement sa cible
permettez-moi d'essayer de lever deux
mystifications la première mystification
le rassemblement national serait devenu
comme par enchantement le défenseur de
la cause des femmes mais si tel était le
cas si vous aviez écouté ce que disent
et défendent les associations de
patientes sur ce sujet de l'endométriose
vous n'auriez pas osé nous présenter une
telle proposition de loi les derniers
convertis compensent toujours la
fraîcheur de leur conviction par la
fermeté de leur expression mais cela ne
dupe personne je vous ai écouté monsieur
le rapporteur je vous ai écouté avec
attention vous mar'artelez bien votre
attachement à la défense de la cause des
femmes mais quand bien même je vous en
donnerai crédit à vous personnellement
vous vous dissimulez mal l'opportunisme
des convictions de votre famille
politique n'êtes-vous pas le le parti
qui avait refusé d'allonger à 14
semaines le délai pour avorter en France
n'êtes-vous pas le parti qui avait
refusé d'inscrire ce droit élémentaire à
l'avortement qui refusit de d'inscrire
ce droit élémentaire à l'avortement dans
votre constitution nêtes-vous pas le
parti dont les eurodéputés se sont
abstenus dans la résolution visant à
condamner fermement l'interdiction quasi
totale de l'avortement en Pologne
n'êtes-vous pas enfin le parti qui avait
refuser la résolution visant à
reconnaître l'endométriose comme une
affection de longue durée en 2022 allez
une dernière v pas le parti qui avait
refusé de voter la loi renforçant la
lutte contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes est-ce que je dois continuer
vos brillant fait d'armes est-ce que je
dois continuer la liste de votre
brillante contribution à la cause des
femmes la seconde mystification concerne
la rédaction elle-même du texte que vous
soumettez à la discussion premièrement
les textes actuels et ça vous ça vous a
été dit et notamment par le ministre
permet déjà d'attribuer une
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapé aux personnes
atteintes d'endométrioses qui en ont
besoin c'est la réalité deuxièmement les
endométrioses relèvent d'ors et déjà de
la définition de l'affection longue
durée 31 car elle n'existe pas une forme
unique de la maladie enfin dans l'exposé
des voctif monsieur le rapporteur vous
exposez quatre stades de la maladie
alors que cette définition n'existe plus
au sein du corps médical voilà
l'illustration s'il en fallait à nouveau
de votre méconnaissance totale du sujet
et de votre peu d'intérêt aussi sur le
fond pour cette cause car cela je vous
l'avais signalé en commission mais en
persistant étaler votre ignorance vous
montrez surtout que même lorsque nous
essayons d'être construit conructif avec
vous cela ne vous intéresse pas ce qui
vous intéresse c'est la gesticulation
voilà la triste vérité aucune des
dispositions que vous proposé n'apporte
de nouveautés un texte vite réfléchi
vite rédigé vite de sens et vite
d'utilité et pourtant trop longtemps
l'endométriose a été ignorée du grand
public puisqu'elle touche à l'aspect le
plus intime d'une femme à savoir sa
santé gynécologique l'endométrios c'est
pour 2 millions de femmes qui en sont
concernées une douleur importante ça a
été rappelé qui pendant les règles et
au-delà PE vous clouer au lit des
difficultés à dormir ou à faire du sport
l'impossibilité d'assister à des
rendez-vous professionnels ou de porter
des projets parentaux auxquels il faut
aussi renoncer en moyenne l'endométriose
ça a été dit et repéré après 7 ans
d'érances médicales 7 ans pendant
lesquels la maladie évolue s'installant
souvent de manière irréversible dans le
corps des femmes c'est beaucoup trop et
le gouvernement n'a heureusement pas
attendu cette triste journée pour agir
et ça a été rappelé grâce à l'engagement
du président de la République à travers
la stratégie nationale de lutte contre
l'endométriose de février 2022 de la
France est l'un des premiers pays à
faire de l'endométriose un véritable
sujet de santé publique mais beaucoup
reste à faire le ministre l'a rappelé et
les principales associations de
patientes souhaitent aujourd'hui que le
diagnostic soi facilité elles auraient
dû vous le dire si vous les aviez écouté
que le parcours de soins soit adapté
elles auraient pu vous le dire si vous
aviez écouté et que les acteurs de santé
soient mieux formés et que la maladie
soit mieux connue face à ce texte
totalement hors sujet malheureusement
vous l'aurez compris le groupe horizon
qui est en général un groupe constructif
ne votera pas ses disposition qu' le
sont copie absolument
zéro merci monsieur le
député pour le groupe écologiste 5
minutes pour Madame Sandrine
Rousseau monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la question de l'endométriose
dit beaucoup du rapport de nos sociétés
aux femmes il s'agit d'une maladie
inflammatoire chronique qui se
caractérise par le développement de la
muqueuse utérine en dehors de l'utérus
et qui conduit à des douleurs terribles
pour les personnes qui en sont atteintes
trouble digestif urinair fatigu
invalidante règles douloureuses et
cetera et cetera c'est une maladie
ancienne sous l'Antiquité déjà des
personnes se plaignaient de symptômes
similaires peut-être même est-elle à
l'origine de l'hystérie quand
souvent comme souvent pardon quand il
s'agit de la santé des femmes nous avons
du retard il aura donc fallu attendre
des siècles pour que la question des
douleurs des femmes soi prises au
sérieux elles qui sont en permanence
accusé de chipoter simuler ou exagérer
mais le chemin est encore long très long
savez-vous dans quel cadre
l'endométriose est le plus souvent
diagnostiqué pas en raison des plaintes
de douleurs récurrentes lors de rapports
sexuels ou des menstruation mais parce
que l'endométriose est une des premières
causes
d'infertilité et en attendant de pouvoir
faire des enfants bien des femmes sont
traitées juste sur la douleur ou
s'entendent dire que le sujet ne sera
traité que lorsqu'elles voudront
enfanter et qu'en attendant elles
peuvent prendre des dispositifs
hormonaux pour endormir les symptômes
l'endométriose symbolise à elle seule le
rapport de notre société aux femmes
toujours nous voir à travers du prisme
de notre capacité à procréer et non pas
de notre capacité à jouir de notre
propre corps hier j'entrai dans la
commission des finances quand un député
RN tempété contre le fait que les femmes
ne fassent plus d'enfants durant tout le
débat sur les retraites la quasittalité
des prises du de parole du groupe
rassemblement national porté sur le fait
que les femmes doivent faire des enfants
Marine Le Pen avait dénoncé en 2012 la
multiplication des avortement de confort
prenez le déremboursement de l'IVG vous
parlez de démographie en continu la
réalité est que votre obsession n'est
pas la santé des femmes mais leur
capacité à procréer pour contrer votre
peur irrationnel de ce que vous appelez
le grand
remplacement si le RN cherchait
réellement l'émancipation des femmes il
n'aurait pas été contre l'allongement
des délaiis légaux de recours à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ça a été dit plusieurs fois il lutterait
activement contre les violences faites
aux femmes et il ne perdrait pas son
temps en fausse panique morale sur
l'écriture inclusive il ne soutiendrait
pas des régimes ouvertement
réactionnaire sur la place et le droit
des femmes mais aussi des personnes
LGBTQ Cu à plus cette proposition de loi
est un coup politique sur le dos des
femmes nous féministes nous savons que
jamais jamais nous ne pourrons compter
sur vous pour nos droits votre seule
préoccupation est un agenda politique
Rance et je m'adresse à vous maintenant
collègu de la majorité quand
réagirez-vous quand mettrez-vous
réellement tous les moyens à votre
disposition pour lutter contre la montée
de l'extrême droite
avanth sur ces bancs certains ont
applaudi la prise de parole du
rassemblement national sur l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas mais vous savez
qu'un député de l'Urban a ouvert une
librairie
négationniste le père a parlé de détails
de l'histoire en parlant des chambres à
gaz vous les avez laissé dérouler là
vous nous servez les grands mots la
grande cause et cetera elle est où la
grande cause elle est où la grande
cause une résolution a été votée ici
grâce à Clémentine Autin il suffisait
d'un décret juste d'un décret pour que
le rassemblement national ne présente
pas cette loi il est où le
décret ces gens ont la stratégie des
coucous ils prennent nos combat ils
prennent nos luttes ils prennent nos
mots ils prennent nos auteurs ils
prennent nos autrices avec Simone de
beauoir réveillez-vous le groupe
écologiste s'opposera à cette loi et
s'opposera toujours au tentativ
récuption deus des femmes pour autre
chose que notre liberté a disposé de
notre cors nos cors nos choix cors
l merci madame la députée pour le groupe
GDR chers
collègu monsieur Stéphan pe pour 5
minutessurés
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues la douleur
des femmes a toujours été eémiser
ou passer sous silence quand elle ne
faisait pas l'objet de caricature le
corps des hommes a longtemps été la
mesure de toute chose pas celui des
femmes forcément douillett sinon
hystérique aussi il n'est pas étonnant
que l'endométriose cette maladie qui ne
qui ne touche que les femmes et qui a
pourtant été identifié il y a déjà 170
ans etant sans tarder à faire l'objet
d'une prise de conscience collective ce
sont pourtant des millions de femmes
probablement entre 2 et 3 millions en
France qui sont affectés par cette
maladie chronique et pour l'instant
incurable source de souffrance et de
symptômes très pénalisants une affection
qui empoisonne la vie quotidienne mais
qui pèse également sur la vie
professionnelle puisqu'elle implique
bien souvent des difficultés à supporter
la station debout des problèmes de
concentration lié à la douleur une
fatigue chronique autant de symptômes
qui rendent le qui rendent le travail
difficile et qui peuvent logiquement
entraîner des absences fréquentes ainsi
près de la moitié des femmes qui sont
atteintes d'endométriose considèrent que
leur maladie a des conséquences sur le
déroulement de leur carrière or malgré
ce constat alarmant seul 0,5 % des
femmes atteintes soit 14000 patientes
bénéficient à ce jour de la
reconnaissance de la pathologie comme
affection de longue durée l'annonce
d'Emmanuel Macron d'une stratégie
nationale sur l'endométriose notamment
sur la recherche a constitué un premier
pas mais le la véritable avancée a été
l'adoption ici à l'unanimité de la
résolution portée par notre collègue
Clémentine hatin en janvier 2022
demandant au gouvernement une
reconnaissance en AL3 de l'endométriose
une reconnaissance permettant l'égalité
de toutes les femmes quant aux condition
de remboursement de leurs soins et
Monsieur le Ministre quel que soit
l'agence régionale de santé dont elles
dépendent on peut regretter que le
gouvernement n'it pas profité de cette
unanimité pour transformer l'essai et
qu'il n'est pas concrétisé cette mesure
qui est au cœur des revendications des
associations faire entrer par décret
l'endométrio sur la liste des AL 30
ainsi que les patientes afin que les
patientes accèdent de manière
automatique à une prise en charge
complète par la sécurité
sociale le gouvernement le a fait perdre
du temps et de l'espoir il a aussi
offert une opportunité au rassemblement
national pour s'acheter une conduite il
faut le dire ici et à cet instant la
liste des combats que le rassemblement
national a mené contre le droit des
femmes est très longue sur l'avortement
ça a été dit sur la PMA le
déremboursement de l'ivvg réputé de
confort ou encore la proposition de
suppression du ministère sur l'égalité
homme femme nous reconnaissons
volontiers que cela peut constituer un
fardeau encombrant que le rassemblement
national voudrait on le comprend
dissimulé c'est le seul objet de cette
loi opportuniste son article 1 est en
effet sans objet puisque l'ajout d'une
affection à la liste des AL relève d'un
décret quant à son article 2 il ne
répond aucunement aux demandes formulé
par les associations il est même une
source de stigmatisation loin des
attentes des femmes qui on en sont
atteintes la proposition qui nous est
faite aujourd'hui singe les apparences
d'une loi de progrès pour les femmes
elle n'est en réalité porteuse d'aucune
avancée des pistes existaient pourtant
pour des progrès immédiats elle aurait
pu inspirer les rédacteurs je pense par
exemple à l'exemplarité de la mairie de
Saint-Ouin et de son maire Karim boamram
qui a fait le choix de permettre à ses
employés municipales souffrant de règles
douloureuses ou d'endométriose de
prendre un congé menstruel mais les
avancées concrèt ne sont pas l'objet de
cette proposition c'est pourquoi les
députés du groupe JDR ne prendront pas
part au vote mais profiteront de cette
occasion pour appeler au gouvernement sa
responsabilité à prendre un décret sans
tarder je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député nous
poursuivons avec le groupe lot 5 minutes
pour Laurent
panifous
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues l'endométriose cette maladie
qui concerne tant de femmes cette
maladie au contour parfois flou aux
conséquences multiples doit faire
l'objet de toute notre attention nous
souhaitons évidemment apporter aux
personnes atteintte le soutien et la
solidarité qui s'impose les pistes
d'amélioration sont nombreuses nous
devons d'abord faire porter nos efforts
sur la recherche permettre aux femmes
atteintes d'endométriose d'avoir
l'assurance d'un diagnostic précoce qui
donne lieu à des traitements adaptés et
efficaces peut-être même faut-il aller
jusqu'à la systématisation d'un
diagnostic gratuit mais cela ne suffira
pas sans un véritable effort mené sur la
formation des professionnels sur
l'accompagnement et le parcours de soins
car c'est la priorité exprimée par les
patientes en renforçant la connaissance
et la reconnaissance de la maladie par
les soignants on améliore les soins et
l'accompagnement spécifique aux
problématiques liées à
l'endométriose il est évident qu'une
meilleure prise en charge passe par
l'exonération des frais de santé quand
c'est possible et nécessaire en
reconnaissant la difficulté d'accès ou
de maintien dans l'emploi que ces
maladies peuvent parfois générer oui
nous devons agir plus et concrètement
sur tous ces points mais ce n'est pas ce
que ce texte propose aujourd'hui de fait
l'article 1er suggère de créer un cas
particulier pour cette maladie en créant
une exonération spécifique et totale
pour l'endométriose en dehors de tous
les dispositifs existants mais sur quel
critère et pourquoi uniquement cette
pathologie pourquoi pas l'arthrose
l'hypertension ou d'autres alors on peut
regretter que la proposition de
résolution de la députée hatin votée ici
n'a pas été suivie de fait par le
gouvernement on peut regretter que le
gouvernement n'est pas encore saisi la
Haute Autorité de Santé pour que soit
défin une forme sévère de cette maladie
à afin que par décret elle puisse être
inscrite à la ld30 on peut regretter
enfin que le gouvernement est attendu le
27 septembre dernier pour diffuser une
circulaire qui vise à préciser ou
faciliter l'application de la stratégie
nationale du 11 février
2022 mais il existe tant de formes de
cette maladie aux conséquences si
différentes de la plus invalidante à la
forme asymptommatique ce qui rend votre
proposition
irréaliste ensuite dans son article 2 la
prop de loi veut permettre aux femmes
atteintes d'endométriose d'une de
bénéficier d'une reconnaissance de
travailleurs handicapés de manière
systématique pourquoi là encore créer un
lien systématique entre une pathologie
et une reconnaissance de travailleurs
handicapés qui remettrait en cause le
principe même de distinction entre
maladie et handicap et qui ne tient
toujours pas compte de la grande
diversité de cette maladie êtes-vous
certain que les plus de 2 millions de
femmes atteintes d'endométriose veulent
toutes être reconnu travailleurs
handicapés je ne le crois pas enfin ce
que ce texte n'aborde pas c'est la
question des effets psychologiques de la
santé mentale en lien avec
l'endométriose c'est une préoccupation
forte passée sous silence à nos yeux
donc cette proposition de loi méconnaît
la réalité de l'endométriose et nous
regrettons qu'un sujet si attendu de la
part des patientes fasse l'objet d'une
forme d'instrumentalisation
oui trop de femmes sont aujourd'hui
porteuses de cette maladie et ne sont
pas diagnostiqué oui nous devons agir
concrètement pour permettre aux femmes
atteintes d'endométriose d'être mieux et
plus rapidement diagnostiqué afin
qu'elle soit prise en charge et soigné
et c'est ici au gouvernement de prendre
ses responsabilités monsieur le ministre
c'est à vous d'agir maintenant pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe Lyot ne
votera pas cette proposition de loi je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
le groupe Renaissance 5 minutes pour
madameonique
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous sommes ici pour examiner
une proposition de loi mais plus qu'un
texte c'est ce qu'on appelle une
manipulation que nous allons examiner
une manipulation basse politicienne qui
instrumentalise la détresse et la
souffrance de millions de femmes si
encore le fond de ce que nous examinons
était de bon sens on aurait pu dire que
vous essayez de rattraper le programme
de Madame Le Pen qui n'a jamais pu
jamais su s'adresser aux femmes de ce
pays on aurait préféré voir ses auteurs
voter la loi visant à améliorer les
conditions de l'IVG soutenir l'ouverture
de la PMA pour toutes vote même la
résolution visant à reconnaître
l'endométriose comme une affection
longue durée mais non le RN ne peut
arriver à cacher le fond de sa pensée et
nous l'avons encore entendu très
récemment dans cette hémicycle les
femmes devraient rester à la maison au
foyer vous en conviendrez je crois
toutes et tous les récentes positions de
vote dans cette assemblée comme au
Parlement européen sont bien plus
éloquantes que n'importe quelle
discussion générale quand on dit être en
faveur de la santé des femmes la
première chose mesdames et messieurs
c'est de les écouter et d'écouter les
associations qui les accompagnent or
cette proposition de loi n'est bonne ni
sur le fond ni sur la forme car dans ce
texte au-delà de son inutilité on aurait
pu se payer le luxe d'être inoffensif il
ne l'est pas sur la forme tout le monde
a pu voir que cette proposition de loi
est mal préparée sans l'apport majeur
des associations qui travaillent sur le
sujet et montre qu'il y a bien davantage
une volonté d'instrumentalisation que de
concrétisation réelle pour les femmes
sur le fond la liste des approximations
erreurs et autres malhonnêteté est
longue allez quelques exemples des
pépites vous parlez des stades 1 2 3 4 5
de l'endométriose il n'en existe que
quatre vous dites que l'endométriose ne
concerne que les femmes en mesure de
procréer l'endométriose peut aussi
intervenir avant la puberté et à la
ménopause vous évoquez un chemin vers la
guérison laissez-moi vous rappeler qu'il
n'existe aujourd'hui aucun traitement
qui permet de guérir de cette maladie en
réalité vous faites des raccourcis dans
l'article 1 vous associez
systématiquement la maladie à la
reconnaissance de l'affection longue
durée dit al30 or toutes les
endométrioses ne nécessitent pas un
parcours de soin et bénéficier de la de
l'affection longue durée c'est déjà
possible et sous un format plus
protecteur le format al 31 et en 2022
c'est
13472 femmes qui sont atteintes
d'adambétriose et qui bénéficient de ce
statut
l'ALD 31 permet un remboursement à 100 %
et la limitation de jours de carence en
cas d'arrêt de travail consécutif au
même titre que la ld30 la ld31 elle
n'est pas conditionnée à des critères
médicaux restrictifs et elle permet donc
une prise en charge plus large des
symptômes de la maladie et c'est ça
l'enjeu cela répond à toutes les formes
diverses de la maladie ce que ne
permettrait pas une liste restrictives
des critères adossés à la ld30 qui elle
de fait exclurait un bon nombre de
femmes de la prise en charge aussi et je
m'adresse à monsieur le rapporteur lors
de vos éditions certaines associations
confirmait cette difficulté à classifier
l'endométriose en al30 ainsi que la
Haute Autorité de Santé raccourci encore
dans l'article 2 qui est tout aussi
contreproductif il prétend permettre aux
femmes souffrant d'endométriose de
bénéficier de la reconnaissance de la
qualité de travailleurs handicapés or
c'est déjà possible monsieur le
rapporteur et une des lectures un peu
plus attentiv du rapport de la
délégation droits des femmes de nos
collègues du Sénat vous aurez éclairé
sur le fait que des femmes recourent peu
à cette possibilité en raison de leurs
craintte d'être stigmatisé et non d'un
vide juridique alors arrêtez de faire
des raccourcis entre maladie et statut
RQTH et arrêter d'appeler les femmes
atteintes d'endométriose des victimes
elles ne sont pas victimes elles sont
malades cette PPL témoigne tout autant
du manque d'intérêt et de la
méconnaissance du RN pour le sujet de la
santé des femmes que de l'écoute des
associations qui elles veulent un
diagnostic plus précoce un parcours de
soins adapté et une amélioration des
soins et nous ne vous avons pas attendu
nous le faisions dès 2019 avec un plan
d'action présenté par agès Buzin
renforcé par la stratégie nationale en
2022 que nous mettons en œuvre c'est 30
millions d'euros qui sont donnés à la
recherche c'est la mise en place des
filières médicales dédié à l'endométrios
sur l'ensemble du territoire qui permet
une prise en charge pluridisciplinaire
et c'est l'approfondissement de la
formation des professionnels de la santé
sur le sujet finalement que voyons-nous
que le réel que le RN fait avec la santé
des femmes ce qu'il fait sur tous les
sujets du superficiel de l'éphémère et
de la démagogie quand on gratte on
découvre qu'il n'y a ni travail ni
empathie juste un profond désintérêt
pour la France et les Français alors non
ni la santé des femmes ni l'endométriose
ne seront votre caution
féministe merci madame la députée
dernière intervenante au titre des
nonincrits pour 5 minutes madame
Emmanuel
Ménard
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues j'ai pour principe politique
de refuser toutes les lois qui viennent
du RN ces propos ce sont ceux de Madame
la Ministre Beranger Couillard je vous
le dis ces propos me choque et il me
choque d'autant plus que nous examinons
un texte qui parle de l'endométriose une
pathologie qui touche selon
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé près
de 10 % des femmes et des filles en âge
de procréé à l'échelle mondiale 690
millions de personnes et environ même
s'il est encore difficile de les
dénombrer avec précision entre 2 et 4
millions de femmes en France madame la
ministre Couillard nous a même dit être
totalement favorable à un décret qui
pourrait contit la démarche du
rassemblement national ainsi madame la
ministre pour contrer le rassemblement
national serait prête à faire son
travail on croit rêver quelle ironie et
surtout quelle irresponsabilité est-ce
vraiment l'heure face à cette maladie
chronique que malheureusement nous
n'arrivons pas à soigner est-ce vraiment
l'heure de faire de la politique
politicienne de faire de la tambouille
sur le dos des femmes qui souffrent
je ne le crois
pas il est grand temps au contraire de
prendre cette question à bras le corp
parce que les millions de Françaises qui
voient chaque jour leur vie empoisonné
par l'endométriose doivent enfin être
prises en considération parce que cette
maladie chronique est associée à des
douleurs aigues et perturbantes au
moment des règles ou pendant les
rapports sexuels et qu'elle peut
également provoquer une infertilité
parce qu'il n'existe pas de remède cont
contre l'endométriose les traitements
actuels ne visent qu'à en soulager les
symptômes parce qu'il est toujours
complexe de diagnostiquer la pathologie
et que le manque de prévention ne permet
pas de bénéficier d'un diagnostic
précoce de
l'endométriose parce que la majorité des
professionnels de santé ne sait pas
toujours que des douleurs pelviennes
pénibles et perturbantes ne sont pas
normales ce qui implique que les femmes
qui pourraient bénéficier de traitement
médicamenteux visant à lutter contre les
symptômes de l'endométriose ne s'en voit
pas forcément prescrire retardant
l'accès au traitement existants comme
des analgésiques non stéroïdiens les
antidouleurs des contraceptifs oraux ou
des des contraceptifs
progestatifs enfin parce que les
professionnels de santé manquent encore
d'outils pour repérer avec précision les
personnes les plus susceptible d'être
atteinte
d'endométriose alors oui c'est vrai le
ministre des Solidarités et de la santé
de l'époque Olivier verrand avait bien
lancé en mars 2021 des travaux
d'élaboration de la première stratégie
nationale contre
l'endométriose alors oui c'est encore
vrai un rapport sur l'endométriose a
bien été remis au même ministre Verant
en janvier 2022 qui a avancé des
propositions pour lutter contre cette
maladie
gynécologique alors oui personne ne le
ni une résolution visant à faire de
l'endométriose une infection de longue
durée et portée par la députée insoumise
Clémentine hatin a déjà été adopté en
janvier 2022 à l'unanimité à l'Assemblée
nationale oui tout le monde a posé sa
pierre et c'est tant mieux même si
avouez-le les résultats concrets se font
attendre alors aujourd'hui la
proposition que nous examinons la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
vise à soutenir les femmes qui souffrent
de cette maladie et prévoit notamment
l'exonération des frais de sécurité
sociale la caractérisation d'affection
longue durée et la reconnaissance sur la
base du volontariat du statut de
travailleuse
handicapé comment refuser tout cela à
toutes ces femmes au prétexte que ce
texte viendrait du rassemblement
national c'est tout simplement minable
et même
dshonorant la
cause la cause que nous prétendons
défendre aujourd'hui vaut mieux que ça
alors je n'ai qu'une seule chose à
ajouter que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
discussion générale est close monsieur
le rapporteur est-ce que vous souhaitiez
la parole monsieur le ministre aussi
monsieur le rapporteur puis monsieur le
ministre oui merci Monsieur le le
Président il me semble au vu qu'au vu de
certains propos qui ont été tenus qui
sont soit de l'amalgame soit du mensonge
il faudrait répondre mais je pars du
principe que tout ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant ne mérite pas de
réponse
bref aux autres interventions de nos
autres collègues qui soit non pas
compris mais qui sont dans une volonté
peut-être de travail si ce n'est
collectif en tout cas de travail en
direction des
femmes et qui aimerait croire que cette
proposition loi ne changera rien ou
qu'une seule AL3 permet déjà la prise en
charge je voudrais dire de cesser
certaines postures liser travailler
liseer la proposition de loi une prise
en charge à 100 % est évidemment prévue
par l'article 1 non seulement pour les
soins mais aussi pour
l'accompagnement cette rédaction n'est
pas moins couvrante que la Ld existante
elle permet de rembourser à 100 % les
frais de médecine général et spécial les
frais pharmaceutiques mais aussi
d'hospitalisation et aussi les frais de
transport et de télésurveillance
médicale ainsi que le forfait passage
urgence monsieur le ministre vous dites
que la loi n'est pas le bon véhicule
mais qu'avez-vous fait al pas vous
nommer proprio mais qu'a fait le
gouvernement stricto sensu concernant
une concrète et une réelle accélération
sur une reconnaissance totale de
l'endométriose je n'aurais pas la
cruauté de dire rien car je vous crois
monsieur le ministre animé d'une bonne
volonté mais si la voie réglementaire
est encore la mieux disante puisque
c'est ce qu'on nous répète à l'envie si
un décret permettrait madame atin de
nous couper l'herbe sous le pied
pourquoi ce celui-ci n'est-il déjà pas
rédigé pourquoi celui-ci n'est-il déjà
pas rédigé de façon
satisfaisante par rapport aux articles
que nous avons rédigé le travail est
fait et en l'occurrence il a été fait
par le rassemblement
national enfin dois-je rappeler que seul
0,6 % des femmes sont prises en charge
en
31 c'est important de le répéter et euh
que le reste à charge demeure en moyenne
250 € sur un SMIC c'est énorme comme
comme reste à charge alors
franchement vous connaissez pour
certains mon caractère assez rond je
connais pour d'autres un sectarisme
assez
profond oui le caractère la taille
commence à s'arrondir mais ça c'est
l'âge franchement travailler voter
discussion disc les républicains ont
amendé notamment madame Valentin lisez
les textes je parle pour madame riaoton
vous voterez donc mon amendement
rédactionnel plutôt que de déposer des
amendements qui visent dans le ridicule
je vous le répète collègue rilloton vous
êtes et vous savez que je vous apprécie
la présidente de la délégation dans
lesquelles je suis l'un des membres les
plus assidus alors chers collègues au
travail et pour ne pas être trivial au
boulot des femmes nous regardent
aujourd'hui des femmes qui souffrent
est-ce que vraiment nous sommes obligés
par des déclarations malhe
de nous écharper sur le dos des femmes
et leurs souffrance merci au
travail merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président donc
quelques
quelques quelques remarques à l'issue de
de de de ce débat de ce débat riche
j'accepte pour ma part assez facilement
de recevoir des leçons parce que je me
dis que ça peut toujours faire
progresser je suis moins frayant des euh
procès d'intention non il n'y a dans la
réponse et dans les éléments que j'ai
donné aucun aucune visée qui
consisterait à faire des économies sur
le dos des femmes non et je ne peux pas
accepter qu'on sous-entende cela ou
qu'on le formule explicitement sur ces
bancs je le dis simplement je le dis
simplement je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
nous avons augmenté de 100 millions
suite au premier retour de l'incerme
les la la dotation qui est portée à 30
millions pour conduire les études et les
recherches à la fois sur l'endométriose
et sur l'infertilité si c'était pour
faire des économies sur le dos des
femmes peut-être en serions-nous restés
au chiffres initial je l'ai dit aussi
j'ai indiqué aux agences régionales de
santé que pour structurer que pour
structurer ces filières de prise en
charge qui ne sont pas que des filières
médicales elles pourrai recourir à tous
les moyens dont elles avaient besoin il
n'y a pas de limitation
financière mais je vais le dire
peut-être autrement parce que beaucoup
de députés sur du côté de de la nupes
l'ont évoqué je vous le dis très
simplement si je pensais mais c'est
assez accessoire mon opinion personnelle
si les médecins qui suivent les patients
en al si les milliers de salariés à
l'assurance maladie qui ont ce travail
chevill au
si les professionnels de santé si les
associations considéent que l'al30 et un
décret prix sur la l 300 réglerait du
jour au lendemain le problème de
l'endométriose des femmes je n'hésiterai
pas un instant à signer ce décret il se
trouve cependant que nous sommes dans un
vieux débat entre droit réel et droit
formel moi mon sujet c'est l'accès au
droits réels moi mon sujet c'est l'accès
des femmes à la prise en charge donc oui
je considère que notre travail
prioritaire il est encore de faire
connaître de faire connaître aux femmes
mais aussi aux professionnels de santé
j'entends les rires chaque fois qu'
évoqué le mot webinaire que je ne vais
pas sacraliser mais si quelqu'un dans
cette assemblée pense que quelques
semaines de formation au début de ces
études de médecine permet 40 ans plus
tard d'être toujours au point sur toutes
les maladies qu'on découvre et bien il
se
trompe donc
enfin enfin s'il y avait chez moi et et
au gouvernement une quelconque
hésitation croyez-vous que c'est par des
fonds publices ceux de France 2030
qu'aurait été développé par une start-up
française un test salivaire qui
permettra de dépister l'endométriose qui
est aujourd'hui évalué par la Haute
Autorité de Santé mon sujet c'est que
les femmes qui ont l'endométriose qui
sont touché par l'endométriose puissent
rentrer dans des parcours de soins mon
sujet c'est que les professionnels
sachent le opérer et le dépuster mon
sujet c'est que ça ne soit pas que les
médecins mais aussi tous les
professionnels de santé qui qui est
accès à ça enfin et je veux le dire
parce que Madame Valentin vous avez
évoqué le fait que nous faisions pardon
de la politique
politicienne il n'y a madame Valentin
madame Valentin je vous invite à aller
voir à aller voir ce que ça veut dire
une filière de prise en charge je vous
invite à aller en Bretagne par exemple
ou en Île-de-France voir ce que ça veut
dire quand tous les professionnels de
santé sont réunis autour d'une autour
d'une table et se sont organisés pour la
prise en charge des femmes moi mon
objectif il est que c'est ces éléments
qui sont des démonstrateurs de ce qu'on
peut faire qui découlent directement de
la stratégie dans quelques mois ça soit
la même chose sur tout le territoire
national mais je refuse de vous entendre
je vous laisse dire mais je refuse que
l'on dise qu'on fait de la gesticulation
ce sont des actes concret mesdames et
messieurs simplement on a une différence
vous et moi c'est que vous pensez
qu'après avoir voté un texte vous avez
fait changer la vie des gens moi je
pense que c'est quand un médecin les
prend en charge qu'on a fait bouger la
vie des
femmes bien nous allons chers
collègues j'appelle maintenant les
articles de la proposition de loi dans
le texte dont l'assemblée a été saisie
initialement puisque la commission elle
n pas adopté le texte et nous arrivons
nous commençons évidemment par l'article
1er j'ai pour l'instant deux inscrits la
première pour le groupe du Rassemblement
national alors
attendez c'est pour une intervention la
première pour le groupe rassemblement
national madame Laur Lavallette je
prends les inscrits évidemment dans
l'ordre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
merci monsieur le ministre de venir dire
à l'instant que de décret finalement il
n'y en aura pas ça éclaire un peu les
débats on a vu d'ailleurs la difficulté
monsieur le ministre que vous avez eu à
ramer pour justifier votre sectarisme ce
fut long trop long ça n'avait pas l'air
simple et je me réjouis que l'idée dans
cet hémicycle est surgie comme quoi en
fait vous ne voulez pas classer cette
maladie en al exonérante juste pour ne
pas mettre la main à la poche sacrifiant
ainsi la cause des femmes qui devient
honteusement la variable d'ajustement
des politiques publque cette loi
proposée par mon collègue taché de la
pageerff et l'unanimité des associations
que nous avons évidemment auditionné je
veux rappeler je veux rappeler ici que
les députés du rassemblement national
ont voté la proposition de résolution de
clémentine Autin en mandat précédent
nous sommes donc ici en parfaite
cohérence cohérence qui ne vous étouff
pas députés de la majorité vous qui
arborez ce ruban rose que nous arborons
tous de façon très transpartisane je ne
doute pas que s'il y avait eu un ruban
sur l'endométriose nous l'aurions tous
ici porté dans cet hémicycle preuve et
gage de l'universalité de ce combat pour
cette maladie mais comme vous agissez
comme une secte vous n'êtes pas capable
de voter 1 % de quelque chose qui vient
d'une autre famille politique que la
vôtre et franchement c'est la
honte quant à mes collègues d'en face
qui osent venir à la tribune parler du
droit des femmes alors qu'il siègent
dans un groupe dont beaucoup de députés
refusent de condamner les terroristes du
Hamas à ses collègues là je veux dire
mes chers collègues vous êtes la honte
de la
République
à tous ceux à tous ceux maintenant qui
ne voteront pas cet article par
opportunisme politique je veux dire que
votre sectarisme Nonore ni la République
ni la démocratie ni la cause des femmes
et vous dire que vous rajoutez de la
douleur à la
douleur merci merci madame la députée 2
minutes il y a une demande d'inscription
et c'est dans l'ordre des groupes pour
la présidente Panau pour la France
insoumise merci monsieur le président
le rassemblement national est une
arnaque vous êtes les pires adversaires
des droits des femmes et d'ailleurs il
est intéressant Madame Le Pen que quand
en janvier 2022 le groupe parlementaire
de la France insoumise nup a fait
adopter par la voix de clémentinetin à
l'unanimité une résolution sur
l'endométriose vous n'étiez pas là vous
étiez aux abonnés absentes et quant aux
associations vous mentez Madame La
Vallette parce qu'elles ont refusé
d'être auditionné par vous et ce qu'elle
demande c'est monsieur le ministre que
vous preniez en enfin la décision suite
au vote de l'assemblée pour que ce
décret soit pris pour répondre aux
attentes de 2 millions de femmes dans ce
pays qui souffrent de cette pathologie
alors oui vous êtes les pires
adversaires des droits des femmes Madame
Le Pen c'est vous qui disiez en 2012 le
progrès pour les femmes c'est de rester
à la maison c'est encore vous dont les
eurodéputés ont voté contre la réduction
des écarts de salaire femme homme encore
vous dans votre programme qui proposez
de supprimer le ministère de l'Égalité
femm homme et de voir les femmes
davantage prog procréé je vais vous dire
vos amis ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire partout en Europe dont vous ne
vous cachez pas vous dites que vous
prenez comme modèle la Hongrie qui
oblige les femmes à écouter le cœur du
fétus avant de pouvoir avorter vos amis
en Pologne sont responsable de la mort
de six femmes dont Isabella Isabella qui
elle est morte d'une septicémie parce
qu'on lui a interdit d'avorter alors
qu'il y avait un problème pour sa santé
Madame La Vallette vous êtes celle qui
demandit en 14 a abrogé à terme le droit
à l'avortement Hervé de l'pino dans
votre groupe qui compare l'IVG au
génocide arménien Rouanda à la Choa au
crime de daesh c'est vous qui êtes la
honte sur cette question et bien je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui comme un symbole
nous recevons justina vredinska qui est
une militante polonaise condamnée pour
aide à l'avortement et nous sommes fiers
de la recevoir à l'Assemblée en cette
journée enfin Monsieur le Ministre soyez
à la hauteur de l'histoire faites le
décret pour les femmes qui souffrent
endométriose inscrivez l'IVG dans la
Constitution pour rappeler à tout le
[Applaudissements]
monde alors j'ai un rappel au règlement
j'ai un rappel au règlement de la
présidente Le
Pen sur la base de quel article madame
la
Présidente la mise en cause personnelle
monsieur le Président quelques secondes
puisque madame Panau a passé beaucoup de
temps à parler de mes amis vos amis à
vous Panau il jetteent le corps des
femmes derrière les pickup il crache
dessus après les avoir violé et les
avoir démembrer d'accord alors je crois
que vous devriez objectivement faire
preuve aujourd'hui de
modestie merci madame la
Présidente nous poursuivons dans le
calme
habituel en écoutant
madame madame la présidentead madame
Mame madame pan vous n'avez pas la
parole madame la Présidente pan vous ne
prenez pas parti vos collègues à travers
l'hémicycle et on écoute madamebout 2
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur monsieur le ministre oui
monsieur le rapporteur l'endométriose
touche beaucoup de femmes en particulier
et de façon nouvelle beaucoup de jeunes
femmes qui s'inquiètent qui sont
anxieuses de toutes ces douleurs qui
peuvent perdurer tout au long d'une vie
oui monsieur le ministre le sujet de la
santé des femmes le sujet de la liberté
des femmes de disposer de leur corps est
majeur et oui le plan la stratégie
nationale endométriose répond à toutes
ces préoccupations ce sont les
professionnels qui nous le disent à
Lille j'ai mené un débat avec des
médecins des gynécologues des
associations des malades tous le disent
mieux prendre en charge diagnostiquer
plus tôt et partout soulager la douleur
en priorité permettre la maternité
permettre un travail et une occupation
professionnelle dans des conditions
normales c'est cela l'objectif du plan
national pour l'endométriose et je crois
que dans cette proposition de loi
monsieur le rapporteur il ne faut pas
tromper les Français non cet article
premer ne crée pas une reconnaissance al
une exonération de tickets modérateurs
ce n'est pas une nouvelle
non les femmes n'ont pas aucune solution
elles ont l'alld 31 cette reconnaissance
qui certes est encore insuffisante sur
certains territoires mais qui leur
permet d'être intégralement remboursé et
si elle le souhaite je dis bien si elle
le souhaite d'être reconnu travailleur
handicapés en 2021 c'était 7000 femmes
qui étaient reconnues en adeld 31 en
2022 c'est 13000 femmes c'est une
augmentation de 43 % donc oui le recours
progresse pour ce celles qui le
souhaitent mais je le dis par votre
proposition de loi automatique vous
risquez de stigmatiser des femmes qui
ont parfois des endométrioses non
symptommatiques qui ne souhaitent pas
être connu en en travailleurs handicapés
qui ne souhaitent pas être en affection
longue durée avec toutes les contraintes
que cela apporte donc notre proposition
elle n'est ni la tambouille ni le
rejetci madame la
députée nous
poursuivons nous poursuivons le pour le
groupe démocrate 2 minutes pour Madame
Sandrine Josso dans le cadre de cet
article premer merci monsieur le
Président comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans les propos liminires donc
on a donc manifestement dans cet article
1 une stigmatisation et une volonté
voilà
d'uniformiser cette maladie à toutes les
femmes or autant de femmes autant
d'endométriose jamais jamais je n'ai
entendu le rassemblement national
s'intéresser aux causes aux causes de
ces maladies et je crois que là aussi on
a un sujet je pense qu'il faut bien sûr
encourager la recherche je n'ai jamais
entendu le rassemblement national en
parler donc je pense que là il y a quand
même quelque chose de sérieusement
préoccupant donc là je le redis une
seconde fois ce qui est préoccupant
c'est de parler d'un sujet
d'instrumentaliser une maladie à des
fins
politiques alors sur l'article 1er je
n'ai plus d'autres demandes de parole
donc nous poursuivons l'examen je vous
indique je vais vous donner la parole
alors c'est l'article 1er monsieur
Valtou c'est vous bon j'annonce juste
que sur le vote de l'article 1er je suis
saisi par le groupe Renaissance
rassemblement national écologiste d'une
demande de scrutin public qui est
annoncée et vous avez la parole pour 2
minutes monsieur Valtou
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Valtou c'est bien
moi merci j'aurais voulu qu'on puisse
que le rapporteur puisse dans la réponse
qu'il a fait à nos interventions
peut-être nous démontrer le le le bien
fondé qui a été questionné par plusieurs
orateurs je l'ai fait moi-même à la
tribune le bien fondé de la de l'article
1 et la disposition qui est prévue je
rappelle que l'endométriose peut être
déjà peut être déjà bénéficie déjà d'une
inscription al à
31 la procédure qui encadre les
inscriptions des infections longue durée
elle est connue elle passe par les avis
de la Haute Autorité de santé elle ne
relève pas de la loi elle relève du
champ réglementaire ces sujets ont été
posés mais on ne comprend pas la réponse
précise technique juridique apportée par
l'probition loi parce qu'il n'y en a pas
là on est sur un article de façade comme
si tout d'un coup on voulait inscrire
par la loi et changer par la loi la la
liste des infections longue durée ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est pas prévu ou
alors c'est toute l'architecture de la
construction des maladies longue durées
qu'il faut revoir donc je considère que
sur cet article 1 on est là encore dans
un article de façade et je remarque les
orateurs du rassemblement national qui
sont intervenus sur cet article 1 n'ont
toujours pas expliqué quel était le
fondement juridique et le bien fondé
juridique de cet article l'apport de
cette disposition parce que aujourd'hui
quand on lit le texte quand on lit
exposé des motifs quand on écoute les
orateurs il n'y a rien comme explication
donc on refuse cet amendement cette cet
article
pardon alors justement nous venons aux
amendements à l'article le premier c'est
le rapporteur c'est un amendement
rédactionnel monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement ça a été souligné j'ai été
le premier à souligner en en commission
lorsque nous avons travaillé alors il y
a un avis comme je suis rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales
défavorable qui a été émis par la
commission mais à titre personnel j'y
suis favorable celui-ci il est
rédactionnel écoutez-moi bien Madame
rioton la commission a rejeté l'ensemble
des amendements rédactionnels dont
celui-ci empreint de bon sens et dont
selon moi la syntaxe est parfaitement
adaptée à la proposition de loi je vous
propose donc de pardon remplacer le mot
victime par les mots femmes atteintes
des apostrophes d'endométriose merci
chers collègu merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame
brûlebois merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur cette
modification est à l'image de votre
texte un manque de travail de
connaissance de l'endométriose mais
aussi de considération des femmes nous
ne le soutenons pas en effet même si
elle est connue depuis plus d'un siècle
qui a parlé d'endométriose jusqu'à
présent peu de monde et pas vous elle
était en effet ignorée de la sphère
publique et il a fallu attendre que le
Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron en face une cause
nationale au côté des associations qui
seules étaient très Activ et je veux
Souter endofrance par exemple donc en
lançant la stratégie nationale
l'endométriose l'année dernière avec
avec des investissements importants
soutenus par France 2030 mais avec dès
cette année des investissements de
plusieurs millions dans la recherche
avec la spécialisation de la formation
des professionnels mais la formation du
grand public monsieur le ministre l'a
dit c'est la formation qui est le nerf
de la guerre comme l'information que
nous allons faire dès le collège il
reste à faire mais nous avons nous avons
fait déjà beaucoup de chemins avec des
filières de soins actives en région nous
partions de très loin et nous avons
lancé un mouvement très positif et tracé
un chemin que les associations nous
reconnaissent nous en avons fait une
cause prioritaire et s'il faut faire
évoluer le fondement juridique nous
serons là nous nous nous en avons fait
jeeler d'une cause prioritaire tout
comme le droit des femmes pour
lesquelles nous avons voté des textes de
loi marquants que ce soit pour leur
santé leur liberté la parité leur accès
au au poste à responsabilité c'est vrai
et c'est texte de loi marquant je vous
rappelle que vous ne les avez pas
voté merci madame la députée je prends
l'autre intervenant sur l'amendement et
je vous laisse répondre monsieur le
ministre comme ça vous nous donnerez
l'avis votre avis voilà comme ça on
prend l'autre amendement sur l'autre
intervenant sur l'amendement c'est
Monsieur
Tangui on prend toujours un pour un
contre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur écoutez madame brulbois
contrairement à ce que vous dites cet
amendement symbolise tout simplement que
nous nous sommes capables de nous
remettre en cause et de modifier nos
textes quand on peut les améliorer et en
fait c'est tout simple c'est la
philosophie que le groupe rassemblement
national suit depuis que les Français et
les Françaises ont fait l'honneur de
nous confier 88 mandats dans cette
hémicycle car nous nous travaillons
seulement à l'intérêt général est-ce qui
ce à quoi nous assistons ce à quoi nous
assistons en fait depuis maintenant 1h3
c'est un triste spectacle le triste
spectacle non pas un piège du
rassemblement national mais un spectacle
que vous avez décider d'écrire vous-même
et que vous jouez lamentablement
vous-même d'être incapable de défendre
l'intérêt général vous êtes
systématiquement dans des postures
minables mesquines indignes du mandat
que vous ont confié les Françaises et
les
Français comme l'a excellemment dit
Emmanuel Tachet de la Pagerie tout à
l'heure la grossièreté de vos attaques
est égale à l'insignifiance du fond des
arguments que vous osez proférer dans
cette hémicycle insignifiante
insignifiante et le niveau d'arrogance
d'arrogance que l'on a attendu d'entre
vous alors que par définition la
situation de la France est le résultat
de vos échecs la situation des femmes
qui souffrent et qui sont atteintes d'
démétriose et le résultat de vos échecs
et que l'ensemble des échecs de la des
politiques qui visent les femmes sont
votre échec nous sommes systématiquement
votre opposition vous êtes les
responsables de la situation de la
France et en particulier de la situation
que subissent les Françaises donc la
seule chose qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
améliorer ce texte vous le refusez
travailler ensemble comme l' très bien
dit Emmanuel Tach la Pagerie pour le
sort des femmes vous le refusez et c'est
cela que vous allez assumer devant les
Français et les Français ce n'est pas
notre piège c'est votre échec ce n'est
pas nos manœuvres c'est votre faillite
et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas notre sens
notre manque d'intérêt général c'est
votre sectarisme minable déplorable
mesquin et vous serez durement
sanctionné le 9 juin 2024 merci monsieur
le
[Applaudissements]
député merci
je donne la parole au ministre pour nous
exprimer son avis sa réponse merci
monsieur le Président je je donne acte
au rapporteur que que sa rédaction est
meilleure que la précédente mais elle
s'inscrit dans un article premier que
que j'invite cette assemblée à rejeter
massivement donc je donne un avis
défavorable à cet
amendement alors nous allons passer au
vote sur cet amendement qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
ministre et favorable du rapporteur
c'est un scrutin public je vous laisse
regagner vos bancs le scrutin est
ouvert il y a l'amendement pardon on
vote on va voter l'amendement avant mais
comme ça vous êtes déjà à vos
ban sur l'amendement c'est pas un
scrutin public sur l'amendement qui a
reçu un avis donc défavorable comme je
ai rappelé ministre et commission est
favorable rapporteur donc à main levée
sur l'amendement qui est
pour contre il est rejeté et vous restez
donc en place sur l'article prier nous
votons le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos ça fonctionne bien votant 277
exprimé 273 majorité 137 pour 96 contre
177 il n'est pas
adopté nous poursuivons non non ça
fonctionne avec l'article additionnel
après l'article le premier et nous avons
donc un amendement le numéro 17 qui est
présenté par Madame
perriigo merci monsieur le Président
alors cette amendement vient de la PPL
déposée par notre collègue Véronique
louvagi au mois de juillet 2023 pour un
meilleur encadrement législative de la
prévention de l'endométriose alors cet
amendement permettrait aux jeunes filles
scolariser au sein d'un établissement
scolaire sous contrat avec l'Éducation
nationale de bénéficier d'une tolérance
pour leurs absences lorsqu'elle justifie
par le biais d'un certificat médical de
souffrir de symptômes de la pathologie
d'endométriose merci madame la députée
je vous informe que sur cet amendement
numéro 17 je suis saisi par le groupe du
Rassemblement national d'une demande de
scrutin public monsieur le rapporteur
est-ce que pouvez nous livrer votre avis
sur cet amendement merci monsieur le
Président chers collègues vous proposez
de reconnaître l'endométriose comme un
motif légitime d'absence à l'école je
crois que vous soulevez là un vrai et
réel problème si l'endomitriose au
travail peut s'avérer être un calvaire
on l'a déjà répété pour les femmes qui
en souffrent cela n'est pas moins vrai
pour les jeunes femmes scolarisées ou
comme je l'ai dit à l'université j'en
profite pour rappeler aussi euh que
selon l'étude andovie réalisée par
hipsos pour la moitié c'est-à-dire à peu
près la moitié 49 % des femmes euh
atteintes d'endométriose les symptômes
sont apparus avant leurs 20 ans ma
collègue Martinez en parlit tout à
l'heure le fait de devoir supporter les
douleurs intenses de ne pas pouvoir se
tenir dans une position plusieurs
minutes devrait être pris en compte il
est donc important que cet absentéisme
ne soit pas dommageable pour les jeunes
femmes qui en souffrent et je crois que
votre amendement y contribuerit et va
dans le bon sens toutefois j aimé un
avis naturellement favorable à titre
personnel et dois vous avertir que la
commission des affaires sociales en tant
que rapporteur il a émis un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Madame la
Députée je je effectivement ce ce point
a été abordé par Véronique louvagi dans
sa dans sa proposition de loi je je
crois qu'il faut replacer de ce fait
l'endométriose dans le cadre de la prise
en charge des pathologies de que peuvent
avoir les enfants ou les adolescents or
aujourd'hui le projet d'accueil
individualisé dans les établissements
scolaires prévoit précisément que les
enfants atteints de maladie chronique ou
qu'elle soit reconnue ou pas en al
bénéficie des aménagements qui sont
proposés dans cet amendement je crois
donc clairement que ce dispositif existe
il est en place pour le coup il
fonctionne au quotidien dans des
milliers d'établissements scolaires je
considère donc que cet amendement est
satisfait et si vous considériez
l'inverse je me verrai contraint de
donner un avis défavorable à cet
amendement merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur
Rousset merci monsieur le Président moi
je vais revenir sur l'endométriose quand
on parle d'endométriose ça demande
beaucoup d'humilité c'est une maladie
qui remonte à l'Antiquité les premières
femmes qui s'en sont pleins s'en sont
pleins et les Égyptiens ont parfaitement
décrit leurs symptômes puis
l'endométriose a permis de qualifier les
femmes d'hystériqu et cetera donc je
pense que parler de l'endométriose et
agir pour l'endométriose ça doit se
situer dans le temps dans la prévention
et tout ce que a été annoncé par notre
ministre va dans ce sens moi je voudrais
vous dire vous du rassemblement national
et à la CIR sens les élé républicains
que vous êtes dans une politique du
petit train euh par cette euh loi
proposition de loi qui n'a aucun sens
qui est un écran de fumée vous vous
proposez de vous raccrocher au grand
train qui doit traiter de la cause des
femmes de leur santé de la liberté de de
de de de l'usage de leur corps voilà et
les républicains vous raccrochez votre
wagon à celui du rassemblement national
je pense que c'est pas comme ça qu'on
peut tirer vers le haut une politique de
santé publique qui doit
appel à beaucoup d'humilité et de
sagesse merci merci monsieur le
député madame
Valentin chers collègues je suis assez
surpris de votre propos je tiens
simplement à vous signaler que quand on
veut aller quelque part il vaut mieux
être dans le train que d'avoir loupé le
[Applaudissements]
train bon et bien nous n'allons pas
louper le scrutin public que j'ouvre je
vous laisse regagner vos bans sur cet
amendement 17 car son avis favorable du
rapporteur des favorable commission
gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos 262 votants exprimés 254 majorité
128 pour 118 contre 136 il est
repoussé nous passons à des amendements
qui sont soumis à une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 11 madame
Corneloup merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre cela a été dit
l'endométriose touche 10 % des femmes en
âge de procréé première cause
d'infertilité en France et ind
diagnostique qui est posé très
tardivement il me semble nécessaire de
prévoir une une séance annuelle de
sensibilisation dans les collèges et les
lycées par groupe d'âge homogène
celle-ci permettrait aux jeunes femmes
de mieux appréhender les symptômes et
les implications de cette maladie dans
leur vie quotidienne mieux connaître
l'existence de cette pathologie
permettra de mieux la diagnostiquer
demain je vous remercie merci madame la
députée le 16 qui est présenté par
Madame Valentin
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
c'est toujours dans le même esprit
effectivement les associations et et les
femmes nous alertent sur la
désinformation qui concerne
l'endométriose et c'est un amendement
qui permet aux professeurs de pouvoir
intervenir avec les associations ou
d'enseigner eux-mêmes dans le cadre de
l'éducation morale et civique un module
sur les différentes pathologies telles
que
l'endométriose merci madame la députée
monsieur le
rapporteur effectivement chers collègues
il me semble primordial de de repérer
ces symptômes le plus rapidement
possible et je crois que vos amendements
y cont y contribueraient pardon
honnêtement et sincèrement je vous
informe en tant que rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales que la
Commission a rendu un avis défavorable
sur vos deux amendements pour ma part
comme en commiss je rend un avis
favorable à l'amendement numéro 11
pardonnez-moi de Madame Corneloup qui me
paraît plus plus précis et je demande à
Madame Valentin de bien vouloir retirer
l'amendement 16 donc à titre personnel
je suis favorable merci merci monsieur
le
ministre monsieur le
Président Mesdames les députés monsieur
le rapporteur je partage évidemment avec
vous la nécessité de donner aux je
jeunes femmes les moyens de mieux
appréhender les enjeux liés à la puberté
mais je pense que du coup il faut aller
il faut aller il faut assumer les mots
aux menstruations et y compris à la
douleur lors des premiers rapports
sexuels puisque c'est un des symptômes
et c'est souvent comme cela que l'on
détecte l'endométriose il se trouve
qu'un article du code de l'éducation
l'article l312 16 prévoit d'ors et déjà
et il n'a pas fait l'unanimité dans
cette assemblée une information et une
éducation à la sexualité qui est
dispensée dans les écoles les collèges
et les lycées à raison d'au moins trois
séances annuelles par groupe d'âge
homogène comme vous l'avez indiqué
l'endométriose
l'endométriose fait partie dans ce cadre
d'objet de séance spécifique le
ministère d'éducation nationale a
récemment renforcé avec les associations
pour qu'il y ait aussi une cohérence
dans les messages qui sont passés donc
je considère cet amendement parfaitement
satisfait alors je ne sais pas si c'est
un train ou quel est le le moyen de
locomotion mais le Gouvernement sur ce
sujet avance avance peut-être pas du
niveau de la loi donc pour vous donner
le coup de projecteur que vous
souhaiteriez mais aujourd'hui d'ors et
déjà dans les collèges des lycées oui on
parle de sexualité je sais qu'ici
certains se renversent et on parle
notamment de de sujet de reproduction de
maladiie gynécologique et dans ce cadre
d'endométriose c'est déjà le cas c'est
pourquoi je considère cet amendement
satisfait à des je donnerai un avis
défavorable du
gouvernement merci je rappelle que je
prends un pour un contre donc j'ai
madame garido j'imagine en contre sur
ces
amendements est-ce que vous me permettez
d'être plus nuancé monsieur le Président
bien sûr mais c'est votre nature
d'ailleurs je vous je vous vous me
connaissez bien
euh le choix de faire des séances
obligatoires effectivement existe dans
le code de l'éducation
à l'article qu'a mentionné monsieur le
ministre en ce qui concerne l'égalité
les questions sexuell et il devrait y
avoir normalement trois séances
annuelles par groupe d'âge homogène dans
tous les établissements scolaires dans
notre pays or ces séances n'ont pas lieu
ou du moins si on on en croit les études
les plus récentes moins d'un enfant
moins d'un écolier sur 5 d'un jeune tout
compris collège lycée a accès à ces
trois séances annuelles confè je le
rappelle la question au gouvernement
qu'a posé notre collègue Marietta
caramanli la semaine dernière je crois
bien au ministre de l'Éducation monsieur
hatal auquel il n'y a pas eu de réponse
et donc effectivement chers collègues si
vous voulez que tous les enfants tous
les jeunes aient accès à ces séances
annuelles il faut aller un petit peu
plus loin et là chers collègues LR je je
je me permets d'appuyer sur une légère
contradiction chez vous vous parce que
vous passez votre temps notamment dans
la discussion budgétaire à dire qu'il
faut réduire l'argent pour les services
publics et bien précisément prenons mon
département la saintonie prenons ma
circonscription vous avez aujourd'hui
chez moi une situation où il manque des
adultes des professeurs devant élèves
dans absolument chaque établissement
vous avez du coup des brigades de
remplacement qui viennent remplacer de
temps en temps ces consignant là
lesqueles brigades de remplacement du
coup sont saturé ne peuvent pas tout
faire et du coup il n'y a plus chers
collègues de temps de formation pour les
profs les profs qui demandent des temps
de formation par exemple pour dispenser
ces formations annuelles que prescrit
déjà la loi ne sont pas autorisé à le
faire il n'y a plus de formation ne vous
payez pas de mots si vous voulez qu'on
parle et j'ai une autre intervention
madame madame la Présidente Le Pen oui
monsieur le ministre objectivement
répondre à aux besoins d'information sur
l'endométriose en évoquant les cours
d'éducation sexuelle c'est un petit peu
capilot tracté voyez c'est tiré par les
cheveux quoi il y a vraiment un lien il
y a quand même un lien évidemment si on
cherche très loin mais vous voyez bien
que ça ne correspond pas du tout à à
l'objectif des cours d'éducation
sexuelle il y a en revanche une personne
qui peut faire de l'information dans les
dans les collèges et dans les lycées
c'est les infirmières qui n'y existent
plus d'accord parce que elles elles
étaient les mieux placées très
certainement pour pouvoir répondre aux
jeunes filles qui sont confronté à ce
type de difficultés de santé pour le
reste j'entends beaucoup de grandes
promesses sur les diagnostics sur la
rapidité qu'il faut améliorer sur la
prise en charge des traitements sur la
détection sur l'information j'ai
exactement le même sentiment que le
sentiment que j'ai depuis 20 ans sur les
grandes déclarations qui ont été fait
sur l'autisme ou sur les troubles du du
spectre autistique on ne cesse d'en
parler et en réalité l'on voit bien sur
le terrain que les choses avancent
extrêmement peu alors oui je pense que
de temps en temps il faut effectivement
une loi puisque vous avez annoncé
vous-même tout à l'heure de la manière
la plus claire qu' soit que vous ne
prendriez pas vous ne vouliez pas
prendre de décret sur le sujet de
l'endométriose merci madame la
Présidente nous avons sur cet amendement
terminer nos échanges nous allons les
voter alors madame Valentin vous avez
retiré le l'amendement 16 oui donc sur
l'amendement numéro 11 qui a reçu un
avis favorable du rapporteur des
favorables commission gouvernement c'est
un vote à main levée qui est
pour
contre
rejeté nous av nous poursuivons avec
l'amendement numéro 13 madame Ménard
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui vise à renforcer
l'enseignement sur l'endométriose mais
auprès des étudiants en médecine cette
fois-ci le le 10 septembre 2020 un
arrêté du ministère de l'Enseignement et
de la Recherche a été publié pour que
que les étudiants en médecine qui
entrent en 2e cycle puissent bénéficier
d'une formation sur l'endométriose dans
le chapitre de la conception à la
naissence pathologie de la femme
éérédité l'enfant l'adolescent et qui a
pour but de faire connaître aux
étudiants les principales pathologies de
la femme alors si cet arrêté a été donc
en 2020 accueilli comme une bonne
nouvelle étant donné le manque de
formation des médecins sur cette
question la connaissance du personnel
médical pourrait être utilement et
efficacement renforcé si on y ajoute un
module d'enseignement en première année
et quand on sait que qu'on rappelle
qu'une femme sur 10 environ est atteinte
de cette pathologie je pense que il est
temps effectivement de sensibiliser nos
étudiants en médecine sur cette question
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
sur l'amendement 13 monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président je
ferai une réponse commune aux quatre
amendements vous avez raison c'est une
discussion commune j'en profite pour
annoncer que sur le vote de l'amendement
18 je suis saisi par le groupe
rassemblement national et Ré républicain
d'une demande de scrutin public sur le
12 par le groupe des Républicains d'une
demande de scrutin public nous les
annonçons nous continuons effectivement
à avancer avec le 18 qui est présenté
l'amendement 18 par Madame
Valentin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai bien entendu
votre proposition de former nos médecins
avec des webinaires j'ai un doute car
les médecins ont très peu de temps ils
sont déjà surchargés et nous en manquons
beaucoup je pense qu'effectivement ils
pourront visionner les webinaires s'ils
ont déjà été sensibilisés lors de leurs
études les femmes demandent une
meilleure prise en charge une
reconnaissance de la maladie et c'est
bien monsieur le ministre sur le terrain
auprès des associations auprès du corps
médical et tous ensemble que nous allons
pouvoir faire avancer le sujet pour pour
améliorer la prise en charge de
l'endométriose donc cet amendement que
propose le groupe les républicains
propose d'intégrer au programme de
première année des études de santé comme
aux études médicales d'ontologie
pharmaceutique sage-femme un programme
de sensibilisation à l'endométriole à
l'endométriose et GES j'espère très
sincèrement qu'il sera voté par
tous merci le numéro 12 amendement 12
madame Corneloup
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement est de même nature et il vise
à sensibiliser les étudiants de santé en
première année pour leur permettre de
mieux appréhender les symptômes de les
de les reconnaître plusutôt et de mieux
appréhender l'impact quotidien de cette
maladie sur la santé des femmes et sur
leur vie quotidienne merci le 6 a priori
n'est pas défendu je ne vois pas de
signataire donc il n'est pas défendu
monsieur le rapporteur sur cette
discussion commune sur ses amendements
oui merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure j'ai entendu ma dernière
intervention que j'avais pas été assez
précis dans mes propos donc je vais vous
faire du du mot à mot et vous faire un
résumé des quatre amendements auxquels
je suis favorable déposé par nos
collègues allez un peu de lecture ces
amendements proposent d'intégrer un
programme de sensibilisation à
l'endométriose en première année
d'études de santé ou pendant les études
médicales comme vous le soullignez la
formation des professionnels de santé
est l'une des clés de la lutte contre
l'endométriose toutes mes auditions le
confirment depuis l'arrêt du 2 septembre
2020 l'endométriose est intégrée à la
formation de 2è cycle des études
médicales vos amendements permettraient
non seulement d'intégrer l'endométriose
au premier cycle mais aussi de l'étendre
à d'autres disciplines puisque la
première année d'études de santé est
commune aux étudiants en médecine en
pharmacie onondotologie et maillotique
je crois donc que vous vouez que je sois
précis je le suis chers collègues je
crois que les amendements numéro 13 de
Madame Ménard et 18 de Madame Valentin
atteignent bien cet objectif et je m
rends et je rends donc un avis favorable
sur ces deux amendements je je
demanderai donc à Madame cornelou de
bien vouloir retirer son amendement
numéro 12 12 rejetons en commission et
je rends un avis de sagesse sur le
numéro 6 de Monsieur poet qui me semble
moins précis puisque l'humité aux études
médicales défendu ne vous plaignez pas
quand on vous donne satisfaction chers
collègues il a pas été défendu
l'amendement pojet ok monsieur le
ministre sur ses
amendements merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés la
la stratégie nationale sur l'endométri
prévoit un certain nombre de mesures que
je ne vais pas détailler ici mais je
vous y renvoie c'est les mesures 11 et
et et 12 sur la formation initiale et la
formation continue des professionnels
parce que je je je ne peux que qu'aller
dans le sens de ce qui a été dit hein
par Madame la Députée Valentin madame la
députée Ménard ou même madame la députée
euh
Corneloup il y a effectivement un sujet
pour je soyons clair quand même en 2e
cycle d'étude médical il est bien prévu
euh une formation dédiée à
l'endométriose donc ce ce dispositif
existe il existe à partir du 2e cycle
donc euh et c'est et quel est pourquoi
parce qu'en fait c'est ceux qui seront
médecins vous savez parfaitement que là
vous voulez faire en première année donc
toute une partie ne continueront pas des
études médicales cependant euh j'entends
cet argument je considère excusez-moi
d'être un tout petit peu un petit peu
sans doute tatillon mais ce le la
composition des études en première année
d'études de santé relève de l'arrêtter
je considère que y aller par la loi
c'est un peu fort mais je prends ici
l'engagement de solliciter ma collègue
et je pense sans difficulté pour que
l'endométriose soit inscrite en première
année dans ce décret de 2011 de cet
arrêté de 2011 qu'il faudra modifier
pourquoi je vous demande à ce titre de
retirer vos amendements et s'il n'était
pas retiré je donnerai un avis
défavorable tout en vous disant que je
ferai cependant modifier cet arrêté
voilà merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
toujours un pour un contre il y avait
une une demande d'intervention et
j'imagine qu'elle peut-être en
opposition aux amendements madame jeuné
oui donc ce sera le prochain tour madame
otin allez-y madame la députée merci
monsieur le Président alors sur cet
amendement quelque chose me frappe parce
que voyezv quand on construit une maison
on commence par les fondations puis les
murs puis le toit et on termine par les
portes et fenêtres il se trouve qu'en
première année de médecine l'ordre des
études médicales répond à une logique on
commence par apprendre l'anatomie puis
on fait de la physiologie puis on fait
de la pathologie et puis en fait on fait
de la thérapeutique donc commencer par
l'endométriose en première année me
semble tout à fait illusoir ne répond
pas du tout aux objectifs et ne peut pas
s'inscrire dans les études de santé puis
enfin un dernier point sur cette
proposition de loi pour lesquelle RN
semble avoir un intérêt soudain pour les
femmes vraiment souligner que quand vous
allez sur leur site internet il vous
offre 17 livrets thématiques vous verrez
qu'il y a aucun livret thématique
consacré aux femmes alors qu'il y en a
un sur la protection des animaux je
suppose que les femmes devont rester
chez elles n'ont pas besoin d'avoir de
droit n'ont pas besoin d'être protégé
peut-être en auront-ell quand elles
iront promener un chien
[Applaudissements]
bravo en défense de ces amendements je
suppose madame la Présidente Le
Pen un pour un contre j'ai rappelé à
nouveau la règle
sauf si vous êtes en défense vous êtes
en défense de ces amendements de deux
choses
l'une soit
euh vous n'êtes intéressé que par votre
nombril et donc vous ne lisez pas ce qui
s'écrit ou ce qui se dit par vos
adversaires politiques c'est
parfaitement possible en ce qui vous
concerne la Renaissance he et à ce
moment-là vous êtes de bonne foi soit
vous êtes de mauvaise foi et c'est
peut-être encore moins pardonnable car
nous avons fait tout au long de la
campagne présidentielle y compris
d'ailleurs un texte un très long texte à
destination des des femmes et pour le
coup la
proposition de que nous portons
aujourd'hui sur l'endométriose a été
défendu je l'ai défendu pendant la
campagne
présidentiel accompagné d'ailleurs par
un clip vidéo de sensibilisation de
beaucoup de femmes d'élus de cadre du
rassemblement national qui précisément
euh vous voyez tout tout le monde n'a
pas envie de faire ça mais elles elles
ont eu envie de le faire et bien
exprimer publiquement ce qu'était cette
cette affection et comment elles en
était victime et comment elle le vivait
donc vous avez le droit d'être en
désaccord bien sûr évidemment c'est le
principe de la démocratie mais je crois
que sur un sujet aussi important que
celui-là si on pouvait éviter les
énormes mensonges à mon avis la
démocratie gagnerait ainsi que ceux
d'ailleurs qui aujourd'hui nous
regardent merci
merci madame la Présidente
et de façon un peu pas exceptionnelle
mais dans lanc un pour un contre mais je
donne la parole à Madame Motin qui n'est
ni pour ni compte d'après ce que j'ai
compris oui effectivement Madame Le Pen
a raison sur un point c'est un sujet
sérieux et c'est précisément parce que
c'est un sujet sérieux que nous refusons
d'amender la proposition de loi queut
vous déposer et ce pour deux raisons la
première c'est que il s'agit là d'une
opération de pure communication pour
masquer la réalité de votre projet qui
est opposé au droits des femmes et
deuxièmement cette loi je le redis et ni
fait ni à faire et donc elle ne
correspond ni au besoins des femmes ni
aux demandes des associations donc je
voudrais quand même préciser que nous ne
prendrons pas part au vote notamment sur
les amendements évidemment sur ceux du
rassemblement national nous prendrons
pas part au vote mais même sur ceux de
LR et je suis très étonné en tout cas
c'est c'est à signifier ici que LR est
le seul groupe politique qui a décidé
d'amender la proposition de loi du
rassemblement national et c'est en soit
un fait politique nous ne rentrons pas
dans cette logique là et nous voterons
contre les deux articles
alors madame cornelou vous avez vous
maintenez je ne vois plus madame
cornelou mais le le 12 est maintenu ou
retiré il est retiré et donc nous
passons au vote sur les amendements
alors qui ont reçu un avis favorable du
rapporteur défavoraable commission
gouvernement nous commençons par le 13
qui est un vote à main levée qui est
pour contre il est rejeté le 18 est un
scrutin public je vous laisse rejoindre
vos pupitre le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat 232 votants 222
exprimés 112 en majorité pour 97 contre
125 il n'est pas
adopté nous
poursuivons avec
l'article 2 me
semble-t-il et j'ai désinscrit sur cet
article 2 la première d'entre elles est
Madame bord pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président cet
article 2 vise à reconnaître aux femmes
victimes d'endométriose qui en exprime
le besoin et j'insiste qui en exprime le
besoin la qualité de travailleuse
handicapé pour cela faut-il
effectivement chers collègues que vous
fassiez le petit effort de lire le texte
car nous disons bien les femmes qui en
exprime le besoin ça n'est pas un texte
général ça n'est pas un texte couperé ça
n'est pas un texte automatique au lieu
de ça au lieu de faire ce petit effort
de lecture vous vous ingéniez tous
autant que vous êtes à quelques
exceptions près exception notable s'il
en est
à dans le cadre d'un concours finalement
qui relève d'une niveau bacassable à
savoir lequel d'entre vous est le plus
grand défenseur de la cause des femmes
qui a le titre de plus grand défenseur
certainement pas vous collègues de LFI
quand on voit le sort que vos chers amis
du Hamas et du hzbollah réservent aux
femmes vous avez perdu vous avez perdu
depuis longtemps mais les derniers
événements démontre que vous avez
totalement perdu le droit de vousos
émouvoir du sort des
femmes quant à vous quant à vous
membbres de la majorité minorité
présidentielle quant à vous monsieur le
ministre de la Santé qui faites semblant
de vous intéresser à la santé qui faites
semblant de vous intéresser au sort de
nos concitoyens qui faites semblant de
vous intéresser aux femmes qui souffrent
d'endométriose vous avez osé affirmer
que vous seriez les seuls à pouvoir
rédiger des textes qui tiennent la route
quel auieux péché d'orgueil mais c'est
en plus totalement faux si vraiment vous
étiez les champions de la rédaction de
texte magnifiqu la France ne serait pas
à genoux la France ne serait pas telle
qu'elle est il y aurait des hôpitaux il
y aurait des hôpitaux il y aurait des
médecins de campagne des médecins de
[Applaudissements]
merci
pour le groupe Renaissance madame
Lebec euh monsieur le rapporteur ici
tous on on remarquer que vous aimez
rappeler votre appartenance à la
délégation aux droits des femmes de
notre assemblée c'est tout à votre
honneur néanmoins forcé de considérer
que vous n'accordez que peu d'attention
aux travaux de la délégation aux droits
des femmes du Sénat dans le cas
contraire vous sauriez que le rapport
publié par cette dernière en juin
dernier dont sinspire d'ailleurs
fortement votre proposition de loi a
spontanément repousser la piste d'un
renforcement de la reconnaissance de de
qualité de travailleur handicapé tel que
proposé dans cet article 2 j'ai bien dit
le renforcement car ici c'est encore
votre proposition de loi qui ne crée
aucun droit nouveau les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose peuvent d'ors et déjà
effectuer une demande de RQ th auprès
des maisons départemental pour les
personnes handicapées comme le souligne
le rapport de la DDF du Sénat si les
femmes ne recourent pas à cette
possibilité aujourd'hui c'est par
crainte de la stigmatisation qu'elle
soit professionnelle ou sociale quand
bien même cet article serait adopté les
femmes
d'endométrios persisterait donc à ne pas
demander ce statut donc c'est un bel
exemple de loi bavarde monsieur le
rapporteur collègue du rassemblement
national vous ne voulez pas nous
entendre mais entendez l'avis de la
délégation au droits des femmes du Sénat
vous qui êtes tous sodisant trouvé une
conscience féministe
merci
merci Monsieur
saintuile Merci monsieur le Président je
me permets d'intervenir sur cet article
parce que l'article 2 nous nous pose un
problème dans l'écriture je veux dire
cela parce que la définition du Code du
travail est la suivante toute personne
dont les possibilités d'obtenir ou de
conserver un emploi sont effectivement
réduites par la suite de l'altération
d'une ou plusieurs fonctions physiques
sensoriell mental ou psychique ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui le droit actuel
permet effectivement aux femmes qui
souffrent d'endométriose dans des formes
douloureuses ou invalidante de demander
la reconnaissance de travailleurs
handicapé et l'article que vous avez
écrit il prévoit
d'ajouter la formule qui rend
automatique automatique le fait que les
malades d'endométrios qu'ell soit de
forme sévère ou de manière
asymptomatique soit
reconnu systématiquement comme des
travailleur handicapés ça n'est pas la
demande des malades ça n'est pas la
demande des familles et donc nous vous
disons que cet article il est surprenant
et je le dis d'autant plus facilement
que ceux qui ont accepté le principe de
l'amendement le droit constitutionnel
réservé au parlementaires je pense à nos
collègues LR vous avez un amendement qui
vient et qui dit strictement cela quand
vous écrivez cet article vous créez la
possibilité de considérer que
l'endométriose donnerait un droit
automatique mais ça veut dire que vous
rentrez dans une liste exhaustive et que
du coup vous prenez un risque d'en
oublier beaucoup cet article nous pose
problème sur le fond parce qu'il veut
dire que les 2 millions de femmes
affectées seront automatiquement
reconnus travailleurs handicapés ce qui
n'est pas leur souhait et vous et vous
cré les conditions pour faire en sorte
pour terminz monsieur le député demandz
de travailler sur le fond quand on vous
répond sur le fond ça ne vous convient
pas c'est dur la démocratie he c'est dur
donc souffrez qu'on puisse vous répondre
sur le fond cet article il est dangereux
il crée une liste il crée une liste à la
préver qui est dangereuse et c'est pour
cette raison que nous le refuserons
madame
J
merci monsieur le
Président cet article effectivement fige
en fait les femmes dans cette maladie
alors qu'elle demande un meilleur
accompagnement donc là il y a vraiment
un grand paradoxe soit véritablement on
est tous d'accord pour se dire que ces
femmes doivent être mieux accompagnées
peut-être que les paroles qu'elles
entendent peut-être que l'accompagnement
doit être un petit peu plus bienveillant
ell ell évo très souvent aussi une vraie
souffrance par rapport au jugements
qu'on porte sur elle don figer les
femmes dans un handicap parce qu'elles
ont cette maladie c'est vraiment
complètement inadapté au regard de ce
qu'elle souhaite au
fond merci madame la députée monsieur
Valtou
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais moi aussi ajouter effectivement
quelques mots au caractère tout à fait
singulier pour ne pas dire extrêmement
dangereux de la rédaction telle qu'elle
est proposée je l'ai dit je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure et je le redis je le
redis à nouveau ce texte n'a pas été
travaillé sur le fond et ce texte est
dangereux dans son écriture juridique